two
it is Monday February 20th
President's Day that's right but guess
what
give it up for the presidents
we don't care about what's I don't know
what's the hip-hop line they go we the
Dead Presidents don't represent me
right you know that song
down for dead president it's like Nas I
think that is awesome yeah thank you
okay apparently I'm the only hip-hop
head here so true
it's not real for that Ethan I know
thank you yeah
anyway guys it is President's Day I hope
you guys are having a nice day off you
know us we come in we work it's Monday
we're here to entertain you rain shine
presidents or no presidents the
presidents they never get a day off so
we're honoring them by being here today
well they actually probably get like way
more time off than anyone 24 hours
they're on call baby how long was Trump
golfing like six months he's working
that's working a year that's where you
wouldn't understand we're talking high
value alpha males when they're on the
golf course that's gonna work dude I
who's uh this episode brought to you by
thank you so much to our glorious and
wonderful sponsors Kudos and stamps.com
who love love
now we've got today a very
interesting episode we having
um
a special caller in an hour
that I'm going to be having
a conversation with
and I'm very very very excited about and
looking forward to this conversation
and uh I hope you guys stick around I
don't want to spoil it
but I hope you guys stick around for
that because it's going to be a very
very interesting
for our our really lovely guest frankly
super interesting
Guy and um with an incredible background
it's not on it let me just put that it's
not a Nook I wish that's what the chat's
all saying I wish uh we're still working
on getting a Nook right yeah I mean yeah
he needs to come on give me the response
Nook and no it's not and no it's not
Jordan Peterson either it's it's nobody
that anybody will ever nobody will see
it coming it's yeah yeah thank you
Michael for the gifted
but one of the most interesting dudes
ever with this incredible background and
he's a comp he's accomplished something
that people thought was impossible and
many people said it was impossible yeah
so I I'm genuinely excited I'm not
kidding yes I know some of y'all
probably think I'm kidding I'm not
um also just a heads up
that Teddy fresh last sale sale is still
going although I think a lot of this
stuff is gone
it's moving fast folks
here's your last chance
on Rick and Morty gear
a lot of people bought this even after
my enthusiastic sales pitch
of the Rick and Morty
Rick and Morty guys
[Applause]
good for wearing in the house when
you're by yourself probably not even
good for when there's guests there
you know what I mean
because then it turns into hey what's
the Rick and Morty guy do all this stuff
and you support him yes you don't want
to wear that like this for example this
Rick shirt that's a tough sell
because he did the voice for Rick
everybody's gonna die Teddy fresh since
a few years ago
right really nice cool graphic though
but uh yeah you can't wear that outside
so there it is huge discounts 18 bucks
for that thank you thank you peace and
love that's Teddy fresh
uh go to the banner
or uh oh there's last chance here just
click that uh
money
give it to ya thank you to my more
importantly today's my birthday let's go
happy birthday my
my dicks my dexier act
very nice got him you got me good there
bucko
um also important uh show note
I just clogged the toilet before we went
live
back I was panicking
I was sitting in there
and uh it wouldn't go down the water
line is dangerously High by the way
because you know whenever a clogs one of
your toes you throw up a prayer you say
just God please just
whatever sometimes the pressure sucks it
down sometimes you know there's a divine
intervention and it goes down so I held
the the bar I held the
the thingy down what's the thingy the
lever the lever okay so there's not
really an official name for that
the flusher boy let's see handle
the flush
the the flusher
so I held the flusher down I'm just
gonna fart and then Dan what are you
talking about
and then the water comes all the way up
and I'm like okay I gotta stop there's
no plunger in there this was like two
minutes before the show was gonna start
I what stuff everybody in panic the
whole group I said the koi's club don't
know what to do I can't leave this here
I'm glad you didn't bring it with you
the the turds yeah yeah you can't leave
it there so it's called a flapper by the
way okay so I was so I'm not crazy I
never heard that in my life me either a
toilet flapper ain't nobody calling it
there's [__] all over the floor maybe
people in the business you know wait
it's not the flapper the flapper's
inside okay bro you're like a Backpacker
it's not it's confusing hold on okay you
just the diagram was pointing at it and
he said this is the flapper but then
when I read it it says that's at the
base
all right come back Google letting you
down you can't these Google like
suggested answer things are wrong
they've gotten so bad tank lever it's
called tank lever
I'm saying whatever that's like so I'm
seeing tank handle [__] I said handle I
think I said lever I mean this all makes
sense you got the valve the the flush
valve the seal the lever okay the lever
the tank lever and clever the bull
that's where you [__] right that's the
that's the [__] uh chamber I feel
like bull doesn't adequately
bold is reminds me of something I used a
cereal out of not something right I
don't like it being called bull either
toilet bowl man so what's the state of
the bathroom right now yeah so
I knew I had to come do the show I
didn't want to be too too late so I put
boxes in front of it and I said just I'm
warning y'all
do not do not go in there I'll take care
of it after the show there's another
bathroom before you guys yeah Panic
we're okay
but I'm hoping you're not allowed to use
that other bathroom though by the way
that'd be awesome you can plug the other
one but I'm hoping that um in between
now and the end of the show God will
have done his thing to intervene
sometimes it does work that way you know
it really does it really does and so so
I say up a prayer
Allah I don't know whoever the [__] up
there the god of their turds in the
toilet
human fecal matter I think that's you
oh oh I'm a God thank you
I'll take godhood that's uh the good
bathroom by the way just because the
audience doesn't know that that's our
good bathroom that got clogged Duty
that's the good one that's the good one
yeah yeah but anyway that's kind of just
what what happened it was kind of
pressing on my mind kind of like the
turds on the bottom of the toilet
pressing and I wanted to uh share that
with you guys so happy Monday
happy Monday
keeping the toilet
yes thank you
so let's see we got some top of the
stuff show so let's just have some fun
and then at one o'clock we'll jump into
this conversation two o'clock
two o'clock yeah uh on Friday we did a
call to Arms
to all of our video editing fupa
Troopers out there to do their worst
with a bunch of green screen footage we
took
now submissions are still open
this tournament ends next Friday right
yeah do we want to clarify and where to
submit these because we didn't really
just post this to the Reddit we're gonna
see them all
okay
post them to Reddit Ian says so here
here's just an example of some of the
some of the good ones that have been
floating to the top that I think you
guys will enjoy maybe to motivate some
of you guys but here it is I've been
surprised man
by some of these
[__]
[Music]
it was me I caused the crash
oh man it was me
oh damn it that was great oh fantastic I
got nothing to do with that you
understand hey keep me out of this
I don't know nothing about nobody
all right that's all awesome awesome
really creative applications I must say
I thought that was great
that one comes from um
the wonderful Super Trooper named
uh
netpiz
netpiss
here's a Gordon Ramsay pesto one oh
brother this is going to be rough the
chefs are preparing customers are
getting ready to eat but Gordon steps in
cook me a lunch out of this kitchen
so that's the pesto oh dude that looks
just like my [__] I can't that's
literally it the white chunks and
everything wait is that my [__] I think
I think that's actually my [__]
oh my God that's my diarrhea
I had for lunch I've eaten this [__] how
dare you I'm sorry Mr Ramsey
that was not even the green screen
fridge as much as that edit oh my God
that was shocking actually and of course
a Mobility Mary one rest in peace the
queen we love and miss you so much the
pesto one was brought to you by it's now
uh fill up with food hopefully not the
pesto
here's Mobility Mary shout out to our
the Creator here Tanner San
hey Granny
very good very good
and there it is I mean lots of good
stuff happening here yeah
so keep them coming you guys this is
super fun the winner gets 500 clams
second place 300
yep
100 each yes thank you
so that's fun
fun
um I don't I haven't watched this you so
we blurred this out Aiden Ross now we
talked about how he's starting this new
platform on Kik where he can just
basically do fraud there
for the time being of course it will
catch up with him so he's just been he's
just been streaming straight up prawn
yeah [__] you is this blurred enough
yeah it's it's double it's like Mega
blurred
yeah what's going on it looks like a
[__] old pixel game blurred I don't
give a [__] porn bro
so what's why is he doing this what do
y'all want to watch on PornHub bro
wide what
just because he can I think so I don't
support porn like I don't I don't
support the [__] the [__] do I want to
watch on here bro I don't support the
[__] I don't condone it I don't support
it
some of those pixels are still very
suggestive
it's almost like an art project with how
like you see the colors here and you
already know the [__] y'all that's good
branding okay bro I don't support the
[__] I don't condone it I don't support
it
like there's so much pink going on there
you wonder what the [__] do you want to
watch like look at what's happening
there you know what I mean makes you
wonder
come here real quick
there's no [__] way what you're just
I don't know why he thinks this is a
flex
it's odd
very strange yeah just watching porn
with the boys
this website is so dope I can straight
up watch porn and do fraud
stream is that bad what what are you
just like great videos for them
do what rate videos for them like one
through ten I used to watch porn have
you ever seen two girls one cup
this is stupid stupid idiots
yeah so that's that just a little update
I guess people are mad because we don't
know the age of his fans well at the end
of that clip he realizes and oh like
wait chat
how old are you all and then you see on
the sidebar I mean it's kind of blurry
but hey you know what's great about this
chat they don't have verify your age
they don't do any mature checks it's all
free baby it's free free speech Free
Speech wait so here do you not like free
speech
not as not as much as Aiden Ross
I'm gonna chat bro
[__] chat still beat your meat yes or no
I don't want to watch this [__] either
bro what the [__] do you have pulled up
yes this is stupid as [__] huh yes you
get a little hard No Cap kill it
feel it
like right here wait how old you guys in
a chat bro there you go
yeah so you know Aiden Ross fans
are mostly little kids
like they're in third period right now
watching on their iPhone kids loved
Hitler Jesus
my bro this is who you become okay
this is who you become bro
you're literally showing porn to
children look at the chat's like 15 14
16.
9 14.
[Music]
also these kids are watching who knows
they're on the playground they're with
their parents at [__] Applebee's
you know there's there's got to be some
expectation that you're not gonna pull
up
certain types of things
Church
you know um
yeah
yeah all right what episode do you want
to watch so that actually might be
I wonder if there if it's potentially
illegal to show that to the audience
like possibly you know what I mean
because like on if you go to like
PornHub
they have some age gating where they're
like hey you consent that you're like 18
or whatever old enough to view this
but Aiden doesn't have the ability to do
that to his audience and that makes me
wonder
and the website does have TOS so the
website says oh you can watch this
website when you're 14 or whatever
probably so
there's a common like agreement that
there are 14 year olds on the side right
that's what I understood 14 yeah that's
not old enough for yeah definitely not
in that hour on page four because the
website doesn't say 18 right I'll be
honest the [__] you see on PornHub
you're not you're never old enough
honestly and this and this is after
they've cleaned it up you remember
before there was like a day a few years
ago where they erased all unverified
content and now looking back I'm
thinking like how can they get crazy
when they get sued big time or something
or like something happens yeah they were
in some trouble I think about some of
the stuff being like some of the girls
were underage or some [__] yeah because
they
there's just too much content yeah that
they're submitting right
crazy yeah exploding Milk porn
well shout out Aiden Ross he's
definitely on a winning trajectory here
so I'd love to see it
you're doing great man keep following
Andrew Tate man
alhamdulillah or whatever he's become
Muslim right
praise be
Super Bowl week one and porn week two
okay
they're off to a great start yeah they
really are
well it okay look I don't talk about
that [__] anymore like they're owned by
state they're it's already owned by like
a mafia criminal organization
it's awesome there it is
um
okay this pissed me off
and I'm pretty sure
that
the reason you don't see it trending
more on Twitter is because elon's
censoring it because I have not seen
this once on trending
or the for you page
but everyone's getting this message you
must remove text message two-factor
authentication only Twitter blue
subscribers can use the text message to
factor authentication method it'll just
take a few minutes to remove it you can
still use the authentication app and
security cue method
to avoid losing access to Twitter remove
it so you have so the the burden is on
you to go remove a service that they
offered you or you'll get banned
you'll lose access because of a [__]
security
method that they offered to you now
what's crazy actually
is they said that the text two factor is
unsafe and that's why they're removing
it
which of course makes no sense because
then why would you offer it to Twitter
blue
right if it was unsafe you wouldn't
offer it to Twitter blue you would just
turn it off entirely he knows that I I
would assume 99 or even more use the
text
yeah I mean I I think that the using the
authenticator app is more secure like
that's not false but like you said if
that was the concern they would just
remove it entirely not put it behind a
paywall yeah money
um can you get
they wrote somewhere where they
Justified it as it wasn't secure enough
can you guys find their statement on
that
I don't think it was it was just like or
maybe it was Elon it was just a must
tweet I mean that that is that is all of
the communication from Twitter nowadays
there's random tweets
um
so not I'm sure that 99 plus are using
text two factor and let's be honest
for the vast majority of people that's
enough nobody's trying to hack into your
[__] account who's like you know
Kevin who works at [__] Chase Bank
well maybe Chase Bank well that's pretty
secure actually pretty sketchy
you know what I mean
there's no social media platform that
have has ever done this
and also who doesn't have text
verification because it's the most
standard and it works great for most
people it's better than nothing and the
result of this is going to be
that it's going to turn off for 99 of
the people and then as he says he's
worried about their security well you
know 99 of the people that gets turned
off are not going to switch over to the
app or security key
right they'll just turn it off and then
all these people are are actually going
to be at a massive high risk of getting
hacked
get do you know like two factor is not
perfectly secure but you have to like
social engineer your way into the mobile
carrier and have them send you a SIM
card like it's it's
it's not easy to do right it's doable
but not something that's happening to
everybody like you said
and if you're you're a high risk of
getting hacked or you're like a big
account or something you don't yeah you
probably should use an authenticator
it's not easy text is infinitely better
than nothing right
this whole notion going around that text
isn't good
it's so silly if you're not a famous
person or public figure you're not
really at any risk here at all
just so silly now are they actually
going to do this he says to avoid losing
access to Twitter remove text message
authentication by March 19.
so are they there's no [__] way he's
going to block everyone that doesn't
because well I think at that point you
just won't be able to continue into the
app until you do it okay I see like you
won't get like banned or yeah I'm not
doing it
well you probably don't use that do you
I have a few options on okay I usually
like to have a few options on right
right is this so [__] pathetic I read
this and I'm like this is [__] ins
this is so pathetic but it's cringy this
man is so embarrassing
you have to pay 11 a month
for the privilege of having the most
basic security protocol on one of the
biggest social media websites
I don't think this is exactly what
you're asking for but this was I saw
this and this was interesting too or
he's replying to Mark ass Brownlee uh ah
I think I sent that one okay yeah uh
Mark or yeah so Marcus is of course
pointing out that this is a horrible
thing
Elon is responding uh Twitter is getting
scammed by phone companies for 60
million per year of fake f2as shut the
[__] up no you're not Idiot paying 60
million dollars a year from SMS decks
like he's the only company in the world
that has two step text verification
every [__] so what does that even
mean
I guess he's saying that
wait wouldn't the fake ones be wouldn't
that definitionally be
the times that it's like successfully
blocking somebody
sweaters getting scanned like if it's
fake that means oh he
he thinks phone companies are colluding
to send a bunch of fake texts I mean
yeah
that is beyond so dumb you can find like
Club Penguin got two-step texts you know
what I mean they're not complaining
about getting scammed you're an idiot
bro and you're a lot you're so cringe
people will actually like this guy it's
blows my mind
you can't blow smoke up Marcus's ass bro
he's too smart for that he'll go tonight
ah here's the uh here maybe here was his
reply
Twitter Twitter should definitely steer
people to authenticator app and their
messaging of removing this feature most
people just do SMS two factors because
it's the easiest thing now all those
people accounts are less secure thank
you Mark ass yeah
I love him by the way he's such a great
guy he was on our show a while ago he's
such a great guest smart guy he said
he'd love to come back on anytime maybe
it'd be a good time to check back in ah
was that before the Will Smith
I think it was actually Mark yeah it was
a very early episode I want to say it
was like 2017 first year of the podcast
he's awesome I have so much respect for
him
MKBHD Marcus Brownlee
2018 January God damns that was a long
[__] time ago
yes indeed five years eh
that conversation
I'd actually be curious to go back and
listen to that because I'm pretty sure
like an hour of that episode is you and
him sucking Elon musk's dick yeah you're
right that's [__] funny Bob and now
here we are talking about him arguing
with Elon about how he's doing a stupid
thing and we all [__] hate you on
here
five years can change a lot man that's
the story of my life if I look back
every five years it's changed a lot I
would love to get Marcus maybe we should
reach out I can reach out to him uh
here let's see what this dumb [__] said
use of a free authentication apps for
f2a will remain free and are much more
secure than SMS then why
are you pay Walling SMS you [__]
[__] like you're so dumb that you would
actually tweet this out as if it's some
justification it's not so obviously a
lie or misrepresentation that's not why
you're doing it why am I still getting
hate that's what I'm wondering as well
yeah if it was just we're gonna wind
down SMS authentication because it's not
secure enough
fine turn it off that I get yeah great
but pay Walling it is so goofy
also the the authentication app is easy
for people like us but like I would say
anyone over the age of like at Boomer
territory it's not that easy to figure
out how to use that app I think the
biggest thing with a boomer is that you
know how it it gives you a code and then
the code times out after 30 seconds or
whatever a lot of time you imagine
trying to copy paste that over to
another app in that short period of time
not a lot of time picture your mom
trying to accomplish that it will never
happen yeah and then the other
option he offers is security key which
is like a physical [__] key right
yeah you have to put in your computer I
don't even know how that works that
probably would work well for Boomers
because it's like I understand this it's
like it's like a key it's not it's hard
to set up
I'll put it to carry it I'll put in my
office desk drawer which is the thing
that I have because I'm over 50.
I know people are saying Ethan is
pronounced Marquez I know I'm making fun
because we're saying it like uh Will
Smith Will Smith called him Mark ass
so basically it's just signaling to all
the scammers worldwide like hey find a
Twitter account of anyone over 60 and
you can pretty much get into it foreign
the bruise on my arm I got the
blood drawn
here
and I got a massive bruise here is that
odd that's the blood of can we have
hearts show again where
it was drawn there and it bruised up
there yeah
huh weird right
that's not the like thing that they
typed in your skin with that's out up
there
yeah maybe it just bruised it from the
tape
no you think they tape me that hard the
the turn the turn turn tourniquet
no no I think it was the character
yeah so uh Elon Musk is such a loser and
again
this is a big deal and it's nowhere on
the trending list like come on give me a
break he's for sure censoring it
uh
I think the trending list is just busted
I don't know if it's necessarily because
the the trends have been horrible for
the last couple months well at least the
ones for me are usually pretty [__]
accurate and I've been clicking all of
those because I love the outrage love
the Twitter outrage
yeah I'm getting pretty over all these
social media networks and then if it
doesn't get any more pathetic you have
Marcus Zuckerberg coming in and being
like hey that's a pretty [__] good
idea
meta I'm not calling a meta I'm not
buying into that propaganda they're
Facebook do you understand what I'm
saying I will never accept meta
Facebook metamie with that [__]
more like Metamucil passing right
through me right
that's a dope uh hip-hop line don't you
think yeah
mm-hmm
interesting my [__] does get stuck in
the toilet so the Metamucil didn't
open that scene oh true
go forgot it was just sitting there
[Music]
think about it hold it in your mind
Olivia there's a giant turd just sitting
in the toilet I am holding water all the
way up to the lab
[Music]
pass him right through me like Metamucil
gotta figure got a like a missile coming
out my butt
[Music]
and then you place some tinsel making
cool sounds oh then take a dump in the
potty potty make a doo-doo I should be
[__] on my kids training party so it
don't get uh clogged
hmm I [__] in my son's training party I
throw the turds over the fence to my
neighbors then I got no problem they
think it's their dog it's way too big
but what do they they're never suspect
me
pass him right through me like Madame
you Soul play intenso shooting missiles
from my ass
all over the floor thank you Zach
[Music]
that was important get that off my chest
So Meta
you remember how they get all [__]
testy about it too when we were doing
the metaverse
whenever I go so you guys work for
Facebook they go meta
we don't say Facebook
I make Meats now smoking these meats so
Facebook is testing a subscription
service which will allow Instagram and
Facebook users to pay to get verified
costing 12 dollars
how was it worth that much
12 a month bro
I don't know like it's more isn't it
more than Twitter blue it's more on
iPhone oh yeah so it's twelve dollars
and then because the Apple markup
because Apple takes 30 well they're not
letting that cut into their margin you
know what I mean because obviously cost
them a lot of money to offer the service
fifteen dollars if you have IOS
like do you know how hard companies work
to secure that level of
reoccurring payment I mean like how much
is Netflix now they they spend like
billions of dollars yeah about 15 a
month I guess you know what I mean
and and you're doing nothing Mark
Zuckerberg you're such a loser
here's Zuck on Instagram and I just
don't they they
looked at all of the backlash that Elon
was getting from doing the same thing
which was massive and were like us too
also as you pointed out
they're not making a lot of money from
it even yeah there was a report that
Twitter made like the amount of uh
subscribers they have
is like point seven percent of their uh
Revenue that they get from advertising
and something it's like nothing I mean
elon's he's like tightening the
experience so much to get people to
subscribe soon it's gonna be like you
cannot tweet unless you pay us
a loser
and again
if anything people on Twitter should be
getting paid they're generating content
nobody be on that [__] site let's not
forget
YouTube's the only website actually does
it
love them for that
well that's not true
actually
I mean that what's Netflix Budget on
shows they spending like billions of
dollars
I mean
Facebook spends lots of money for like
servers and stuff right
you don't care brother I don't [__]
care and what's the end result of that
they make a shitload of money doing that
you know they're very profitable well I
don't care about that says product
announcement and meta Channel this
morning hey huge announcement everybody
get hyped
breaking news straight from the top good
morning new product announcement this
week we're starting to roll out meta
verified a subscription service that
lets you verify your account with a
government ID
and I'm not sending Zuck my ID
like I do know everything about me you
need my [__] a picture of my ID now
get bent do you not need that for
Twitter blue
I don't know no you don't you don't I
love you that's awesome
okay that's so awesome I thought the
whole idea was to prevent imposters or
whatever you don't you don't need to
prove who you are I want to make a fake
account and get it verified on Twitter
I mean take two seconds you got a credit
card and pair of Thumbs
yeah so it's literally all you need
so I guess okay so let's see we need
your government ID get a blue badge get
extra impersonation protection
against your account and get direct
access to customer support this new
feature is about incurising authentic
authenticity sure awoln customer support
by the way they're just going to throw
that in that's cool
yeah uh I mean
what what are you gonna say to them hey
guys uh my [__] [__] well basically
what they're saying is if you have a
problem
you get locked out of your account
something weird something gets a race
whatever pay us and you can talk to us
kind of interesting
meta verified starts at 12 bucks a month
on web or 19 a month on iOS will be
rolling out in Australia and New Zealand
this week
Lucky them oh it didn't show but also it
shows your comments higher in the feed
it's going to do that too that's part of
what Twitter blue does that's what I
read I don't see it here but I read that
somewhere
I hadn't that may have just been
speculation because I read zuck's
statement I don't think he mentioned
that this is a weird service though I
can't imagine that it's going to appeal
to a lot of people I mean
I feel like it's even like
the the Twitter had like a whole weird
culture around the blue checks right
right but as far as I can tell that
doesn't exist nearly to the same extent
on Instagram no Facebook for that matter
so I don't I don't know who's going to
be too motivated for that not there's no
Prestige there
are gonna make no money from this and I
cannot wait well on Instagram there is a
little bit I guess a little bit but
again it's just the uh
I don't know there's a whole there's a
whole check mark culture on Twitter
right like that people put it on a big
pedestal that you don't really see as
much on other social medias I'm just oh
here it is yeah here's an announcement
Mark Zuckerberg announced new
subscription-based meta features include
a verified batch customer support
prioritization and other people's
comments
there it is I don't know if pop base is
credible but there it is
oh wait no here it is
verified badge customer support active
impersonation monitoring
oh prioritization or meta verified
profiles and other people's comments
stupid [__] dumb bro
you get recommended more
wait seriously recommendations and
explore pledge and reels on Instagram
what does that mean
you know how on Instagram has its like
version of tech talk essentially now
yeah I think if you pay for it you'll
show up in people's algorithm or are you
[__] my tits bro also if you follow
someone you're more likely to be
recommended
as like you may also want to follow this
person it's delicious Mass follow bot on
yeah yeah I think this is the way all of
all social media is going to go and
frankly I'm kind of surprised it didn't
happen earlier now that it's now that
it's happening it's like if they're
gonna start charging us then you better
stop tracking my data that's the thing
isn't it
I think this is a I think they're going
that is the game I think they're going
too far with it I don't like it
definitely it's just it's not good this
isn't going to work for you guys you're
getting too [__] greedy mark
what's up
what the [__] Mark I'm the meat shop
well cam
and I were talking about earlier and he
speculated uh
perhaps it has something to do with
uh their metaverse [__] completely
[__] falling flat on his face and
nobody being interested in it because
they spent
a lot of money developing that yeah I'm
sure that the like [__] thousand
dollars they generate from this is going
to help offset those losses right well
how much did metaverse cost
10 billion that's not a big deal 80
billion they've invested they'll make up
they'll make up for that this
can you do me a favor 80 billion dollars
yeah you're a [__] idiot and he's
still he's still one of the richest
dudes in the world where did that money
I know I'm just thinking back to when we
were doing those segments though in in
the Facebook metaverse and it was just a
shitty [__] second life clone from
2004. yeah I don't know 80 billion
dollars I don't know where that there's
some corruption going on on Facebook
absolutely Hunter and Olive said this is
egregious Ian worked so hard for that
blue check now people can buy it I'm
pissed thoughts Ian
yeah his blue jay
it is gross
it's disgusting you literally bought it
no Ian got didn't get checked on Insta
it's organic on it's not he's legit on
Insta no it's not organic Instagram yeah
um it is fully organic non-GMO check
fully organic from in spamming the uh
verification page every couple weeks for
two years let me ask you know what
happened Dan there's gonna be a little
Saucy boy today but that's not what
happened Ian answered this would you be
verified if you weren't on the show
huh go ahead yes sure I'll say that yeah
yeah you know that I'll have something
I got you that check
I got 11 bucks
I could have paid for it you know anyway
I'm all over this [__] I'm I'm gonna get
that you're gonna buy all this [__] good
for you I'll get it [__] yeah do me a
favor um so they spent 80 billion and
then this subscription service costs 15
or no uh let's just be generous and say
they do 15. so the Friendship numbers
for me 80 billion divided by 15. so how
many users are we gonna need 80
I'm just trying to Crunch my numbers
so you would only need
um approximately 5.3 billion people to
sign up okay and what's the population
of the Earth well it's like 8 billion
now or something okay so potential
numbers of okay
7.88 billion so okay so it's just like
70 of the planet right divided by using
everybody on the planet but just just uh
carry the ones to the five divided by
the square root of three actually it's
only it's about 67 of the planet
67. yeah that's doable I think actually
I think that I think they're gonna I
think they're gonna make that money back
well okay in 2001 there was 1.2 billion
monthly active users
so don't talk about making money so
they're gonna need to expand their
client base as well who wants me to take
their money
uh they're such douches I can't wait for
these websites to die I'm so [__]
over them and they're all such douches
it's time for the next gen
just like we I've said it before we just
got to bring Myspace back man those were
the good times bro return to monkey
Tom where were you Tom come back okay so
that's that thank you thank you uh to
meta so yeah we're at 40 minutes so uh
we should probably do our advert so
let's thank our sponsors and then when
we come back is our caller cued up there
uh he's not uh queued up yet but I can
shoot a message and say to hop on and
then after the sponsors you can uh start
yeah so guys I'm gonna thank our
sponsors do not go away
um I'm very excited for this
conversation we're about to have
thank you is anyone gonna buy that meta
[__] other than that
just be honest Amy yeah it's a weird
situation you kind of have to because if
you're trying to grow and it's used to
promote other stuff I do you kind of
have to it sucks I hate it I know it
looks like it's closer [__] why do you
have to because like on Twitter my stuff
has grown like crazy because I have that
it prioritizes really yeah oh that's fun
yeah it sucks I hate it I'm I don't like
it but and so that means
promoting concerts and [__] I mean I'm
getting a lot of engagement on that too
so
love are do you have Twitter I've grown
more their past yeah I've grown more the
past couple months than I've ever had
and I never bought it me too
so yeah
organic baby
it's like two to two y'all just need to
shut up and pay them dude okay no
questions no Natty I ain't paying them
all right let's take our sponsors
uh thank you so much to Kudos
love Kudos actually if you shop online
you probably use an app to find the best
coupons and now you should also use
kudos to get the most cash back
that's right Kudos is a free shopping
extension that not only helps you pick
the best card to use at checkout but it
now doubles your rewards that means if
you normally get three percent back on
Walmart or Sephora or TripAdvisor
whatever you'll now get six percent with
Kudos and that's basically free money
yeah I don't know
I'm not like a big into like the whole
credit card navigating bonuses and stuff
but I do notice that
on certain months or quarters you get
like a fat cash back
for certain categories
and uh my dad's obsessed with that [__]
he always has been
you'd be like Donna don't use my card he
gets mad at my mom she's this wrong
credit card anyone else
have family like that just me just you
you'd legit get angry at her
even now he still does it
just over the weekend my mom has this
thing she wants to buy
and she's like oh I gotta wait till
March I says why she needs it now oh I
remember what it's a sink their faucet
sink is broken
it [__] leaks
and she needs to hire a plumber and she
goes I gotta wait till March I said why
you need it now you're always
complaining about it oh Gary says I need
to wait to put her on the card because
then we'll get a it's like he's sitting
there with a leaky [__] faucet till
March 1st because he don't got the right
bonus
it's crazy dude
and he sold now you can't even talk to
him about it he just shuts he's like you
know what I mean it's like whatever bro
like Mom just [__] get the plumber
and everyone's just too old they're like
ah I'm over it I'm over arguing with him
about that [__]
which is kind of smart I guess at this
point in life
good thing we had a lot of rain
anyway kudosia there it is kudos for my
dad specifically the best thing about
Kudos is that it's so easy to use and
add kudos to your desktop or your iPhone
in just a few clicks shop like normal
and Kudos will automatically appear at
checkout to handle the rest
I was shopping on Nordstrom the other
day and Kudos not only helped get the
most rewards but also reminded me that
all the other hidden card benefits like
purchase protection as well
Nordstrom Macy's
you can save a lot of money with that
cash back business
last month we announced that one lucky
person who signed up for Kudos would get
a 50 gift card to Teddy fresh
congratulations to Frank oh
yes the Kudos team will be reaching out
today
but now we're celebrating doubling the
reward for the next Sweepstake for a
limited time only one person who signs
up for Kudos with the code h3tv will
receive a 100 gift card to Teddy fresh
perfect for the new multi-colored
studded shirt okay
they give a little call out there
or anything you want I mean [__] with
the 100 gift card you could buy like 10
Rick and Morty shirts
might be better as kindling at that
point than for sure
I don't know is kindling expensive
you know what I mean
let's burn some Rick and Morty gear
all right
thank you
so don't wait get kudos for free by
going to join kudos.com h3tv it's in the
link that's join to join kudos.com
h3tv so they know that we sent you thank
you to our sponsor and good luck hundred
dollar gift card to today fresh that's
cool thank you kudos
saving money and
capturing Hearts all along the way
you know what I'm saying 100 here it is
this is the sponsor that is changing the
whole earth it's stamps.com
no the future is no more like we thought
it was no no no
you back me up on that Jack
I can't during ads oh really
no no no what is it he said the future
world is not oh yeah the world is not
anymore the way it used to be no no no
no no no no yeah yeah guys that's what
stamps.com they're changing the game if
you're a business owner small business
owner are you just like shipping stuff
stamps.com is Gonna Change Your Life
actually
2023 is well on the way and maybe you
want to set up a small business maybe
this is the year you get out there and
get after it stamps.com gonna help you
out Samsung let you print your own posts
and shipping labels right from your home
or office it's ready to go in 10 minutes
so you can get back to business
time is money
people don't understand that
post oh yeah so here's the deal posters
rage keep going up it's so freaking
expensive and stamps.com has the best
discounts in the entire industry they do
these massive Buys so they're able to uh
negotiate the prices down with the post
office quite a bit
they're gonna offer you 84 up to 84 off
USPS and UPS
basically free you even have to pay for
shipping with that level of discount 84
percent
but they pay you they pay you to ship it
you don't have to think about something
dude that's not a real that's not a real
law not endorsed not a real offer
plus stamps.com act automatically tells
you the cheapest and fastest shipping
option of all the available ones
they've been open for 25 years these
guys are indispensable to over 1 million
businesses you know there's no lines
there's no traffic there's no waiting
it's incredible you uh use stamps.com to
print so here's how it works you go on
the computer
they send you a digital scale for free
with this offer you weigh your package
your envelope and then you print out the
exact postage put it on the package
here's the best part they'll come get it
you leave it on their porch you can
schedule a pickup or you can just put in
your mailbox or any Dropbox
it's incredibly efficient time saving is
cheaper it's stamps.com
h3tv
it's a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
free digital skill there's no long-term
commitments or contracts so give it a
shot stamps.com
h3tv just go to sams.com h3tv I love you
[Music]
instead
all right is our guest lined up
uh they're in the lobby they are okay so
here's the thing I want to pee right now
because I don't want to have to hold
this in during this convo so I'm gonna
go pee and then I'll be right back okay
I have to pee right now sounds good just
bad enough you have to I'll go check on
the diarrhea it actually wasn't a
diarrhea it was a solid okay that was
the problem right yeah
too far the other direction
[Music]
[Applause]
well how's everyone's weekend
good uh it was good Zach how was yours
did you build any Legos I did I built
Legos and I also went to a fondue
restaurant really yeah it was called The
Melting Pot
I've heard of it very good very good
have you had you ever done the Dew
before I have years ago and I kept
making fondue jokes the whole night and
uh Chantal was getting mad let me get an
example
I
if you do something wrong at a fondue
restaurant it's a fondant so do you have
a whole Netflix uh stand up special
around on fondue yes that's awesome it's
my kauffman-esque uh
over the top should I uh book a
reservation on May 13th to go oh no
actually you don't want to be dipping
your sticks and that cheese because that
is Zach Lewis live at the Roxy May 13th
get your tickets tickets are going like
hot molten cheese I got a fondue
restaurant
how did I know that plug was coming I
appreciate that lay up there again
so yeah May 13th game tickets we'll be
there will you I don't think I'm gonna
go oh
I'm gonna go
oh you're busy I feel like you're being
too I feel like you're being too pushy
Dan I'll tell you what if you go I'll
take you to a fondue restaurant oh hell
yeah I'm back in okay there we go back
in baby that's a fondue not a fun don't
ever that's right
and then uh you know what the bowel
movement is called after a fondue
restaurant no Zach what do you call it
it's called a fondue
fart do is that what you said fondue
like do like Duty it's a fondue
because he could have gone with like the
fart do direction as well we're just
adding an extra dude to fondue do fondue
you know like you're shopping these
jokes work with me yeah
[Music]
um what else did you peeps do over the
weekend well what I asked about the Lego
and then you went off on this whole
fondue thing but I was really I was more
curious about the Lego oh I built an
Adidas shoe
really weekend yeah okay that's kind of
hype yeah
um and then
I don't know they just Ian was telling
me because you know we're deep in the
trenches with this stuff they're putting
out an up Lego set
like from the Pixar movie oh that up
okay yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be
cool like the house with all the
balloons yeah Frederickson all that fun
[__] hell yeah shouldn't you be hustling
instead of building Legos shouldn't you
be building a building an empire
building an empire making websites
I'm trying dude but I really love
building Legos hustling on this here you
have a hobby he's building a Lego Empire
Yeah we actually had to buy shelves this
week because I'm out of space that's
awesome I'm happy that you found
something you enjoyed doing so much yeah
you know as music wasn't enough I had to
get into another thing so Peter loves
Legos I mean and the Lego dude Lego is
on top of the world you go to the shops
not only are they beautiful and their
licensing deals are insane they're like
always have like the newest thing but
it's so full oh yeah it's always so full
it's insane plus like you know walk in
there and
um I'm a VIP member there so it's like
when you go and buy something they're
like are you a VIP I'm like yes I am
what does that mean you get points and
like it's Twitter blue for for Legos
it's actually free believe it or not oh
okay yeah just buying the Legos
um but you build points but I'm not sure
what I think it gets you access your
earlier access we don't know what it
does but it sounds
baby yeah so but yeah I just got Teddy
some Legos over the weekend we got them
uh
this it's a dragon dinosaur oh wow from
this show whatever he's loves it what
the the ninja
yeah yeah yeah so he doesn't care about
the show at all
the girl Legos is like who's your
favorite character sounds like he
doesn't care about that
he just likes the Dragon
all right so let's talk to our um our
esteemed caller so um
set it up first a little bit before we
bring him in
yeah I will right now
all right so this whole thing started
when this dude Mark Elliott emailed me a
few weeks ago
I'll read the email to you guys that I
got
as you guys know uh did you
let me know when that's done Dan
as you guys know I'm a huge I'm have a
lot of interest in Nexium
I am uh a believer
I think Keith Rainier is a modern day
genius
and he's been unfairly
slated as a as a villain
so does Mark
is an award-winning speaker who lived
with Tourette Syndrome for 20 years and
then beat it completely mind over body
that shocked me
that's quite clean and now with the now
Infamous company Nexium he was recently
featured in the third episode of the
documentary The Vow
on HBO we've talked about The Vow on
this show
he actually and good for him he's or was
it he sued hbr or was it someone else
uh someone else uh a different
documentary that was uh on Stars I
believe it was called seduced that was
also about uh the Nexium group
yeah chick chat please Dan
um
you know he said
oh it is okay good now he said I
recently saw your coverage of poking
holes in the Andrew Tate narrative
which is true
um now I've been critical Andrew Tate
but I think he does a lot of good things
too
and it's just not fair all he wants to
do is help a generation of men and then
so what he's the bad guy
men need a voice
that's where me and Mark Elliott agree
given your commitment to pursue truth
and openness to challenge prevailing
narratives Mark said in his email to me
I believe you would be fascinated with
my story and the recent developments
that have unfolded in the case against
Mr ranieri's
specifically seven digital forensic
experts including four former FBI have
come forward with evidence showing that
a scientific with scientific certainty
that the FBI tampered with the child uh
prawn
digital evidence and the trial Keith was
convicted of having child p word uh and
you know all kinds of other horrible
stuff which he's all innocent of
according to mark
also I want to Mark the one thing that I
find really interesting about Mark is
that through Nexium and with Keith's
teaching Mark who has Tourette syndrome
is complete he just said I'm done he did
my mind is more powerful than the matter
and I'm done with Tourette's he said
so he asked me would you be open for a
short call
he says I have no doubt you'll be very
you will be at least very intrigued
thanks for your time so that's Mark
inspirational thinker speaker and I said
to myself I am interested I do want to
talk to Mark
uh and so if Mark is actually on the
phone and you know we've been we've been
setting this up for a couple weeks so
Mark whenever you're ready there he is
thanks man for being here that's so so
awesome to to meet someone like you
that's great thank you uh so much for
having me can you hear me okay yeah yeah
no I can hear you great
okay perfect I heard a little bit of the
introduction thank you for that yeah of
course so why did you reach out to me I
guess first of all I'm curious about
your whole journey maybe you could start
there
well you know as as I had wrote you in
the email
um you know I my myself my team we had
been researching different people that
are Wheeling ultimately to challenge
challenge the status quo right and uh of
course the Andrew Tate was one of the
biggest stories it was an international
story uh and there was you know some
people like yourself that were willing
to at least question right uh with our
situation with Keith and Nexium is that
there has been basically one narrative
for the past five years this actually
started about five years ago it was in
2000 it was in October of 2017
is the leader I guess I don't know
what's the correct term of Nexium and he
was he was convicted for
cheese was like seven different felonies
huh
but yeah he didn't do any of it
yeah so I'll definitely get to all of
that
um what he was he was convicted uh of
many different things including sex
trafficking forced labor racketeering uh
wire fraud yeah now although I believe
you know he's innocent that's ultimately
not why I reached out to you right um it
was given the fact that the narrative
um was you know basically an
international narrative creating this
you know basically was a hate campaign
against Keith Renee and Nexium and the
community sure anyone anyone that was uh
trying to speak out was basically
vilified you know anyone that you know
came out in support of little forget
Keith even just uh came out of support
of Nexium was vilified in the night you
know I actually really support Nexium I
think it's super interesting what
they've been able to do I want to say
Andrew Tate I I totally poke holes in
that like I don't know if you've been
following the case in Romania but like
the there's so many red flags that says
he's innocent I don't know if you've
been following that
I haven't been following it closely
obviously it's definitely been uh
something I've been watching from afar
as it seems like there's just a lot of
similarities in the fact that uh you
know we live in a time that if you make
someone a monster in the media you know
it's you know guilty you know basically
you're guilty until proven innocent
right you then the authorities do
whatever they want to the person sorry
to cut off actually Keith was convicted
of seven crimes though
yeah my the reason I said that is
because before the trial even happened
right he was already vilified and
created a monster you even have uh even
on The Dr Oz Show this was before Keith
was even arrested you have Dr Oz uh
saying on National Television that Keith
uh raped and tortured women oh my now
just so you know even after he was
convicted of these charges and this is
what's mind-blowing for a lot of people
Keith Ranieri who's uh you know this
alleged sex cult leader of an
international sex cult if you actually
look at the charges and the evidence of
what he was convicted for there's not a
single charge this is crazy there's not
a single charge of violence weapons or
drugs and there's not a single charge of
Keith Ranieri having sex with someone
um well let's see here count to let's
see a sexual exploitation of a child he
was convicted of that right I just want
to I just because I want to clear his
name with you so he was convicted of
sexual exploitation he has a child
possession of child pornography
uh he was convicted of trafficking for
labor and services extortion sex
trafficking forced labor
um
attempted sex trafficking so he tried
and failed but in other ways he was
successful that's what they claim right
but it's outrageous that he yeah and he
was never he was never he was never he
was never violent and so that kind of
says it all huh
yeah I want to be super clear there's
most of what people have heard about
Keith in the media and then what the
government you know put out there in the
media as well he is in my opinion
completely false and most of it is
completely fabricated right again that's
not my intent of why I wanted to come uh
you know on and talk with you guys
um obviously if we had longer you know
conversations we could look at more
specifics and things about Keith Renee
and who he is as a person but in the
email is why I got in touch with you is
is that one of the things that happened
right before the trial you know here you
had an investigation of for a whole year
and the uh there were six co-defendants
and this whole case was about consenting
adults and then 55 days before trial it
was also about wire frauds sudden
trafficking racketeering
child yeah so those were all different
charges okay okay even with okay okay
sorry just to be clear though even with
all of these horrific charges sex
trafficking forced labor racketeering
water from the co-defendants
right right
none of them have pled guilty which is
almost unheard of in federal court I
think it's like 97 you couldn't flip
them because they were they're innocent
there's nothing to flip
so the thing is is that 55 days before
trial all of a sudden the FBI found
child pornography and when I say child
pornography
they found 22 photos of a nude woman on
an external hard drive that wasn't on
his computer it wasn't on a camera it
was on a random external hard drive in a
residence that many people frequent it
wasn't even Keith's home so of course
the moment they found that it completely
changed the whole dynamic of the case
where now you have miners involved right
and not only they could have planted I
mean the FBI has a track record of doing
stuff like that I mean they are they're
just Monsters the FBI I don't trust them
at all and I think they probably planted
it but my concern at least just from the
Optics point of view because again I'm
on your guys's side Camille was a 15
year old who tested she wrote a victim
statement impact statement that said
that he took he actually raped her when
she was 15.
and she put out a statement and all that
it's crazy she said she met it when he
was 13.
and then when she was 15 he was 45 and
he slept with her but that that's just
why was she lying like that
yeah so I want to make something very
clear I don't support
sexual assault against women in any way
no any of my friends of course were out
there I just want to make that very
clear that's a very sensitive subject
yeah of course what
what I was saying though and then I will
get to the the uh she did say those
things but what's important to realize
is that the child pornography was was
all of a sudden found 55 days before
trial and then all the all other
co-defense pled guilty so Not only was
he was he charged with possession of
child pornography he then was also
charged with sexual exploitation of a
minor which is probably one of the most
agree discharges somebody can get
against them you know charged against
them which ultimately is a death
sentence for many people yeah one just
to go back to you saying 55 days before
trial it's like it's like when did they
have the time to investigate that you
know
well just well they also had had this
hard drive and this cam this alleged
camera for over a year so yeah that's
the the that's the context which
happened right before trial uh yes her
name is Cami she did uh give a victim
impact statement but what is important
for people to realize is that a victim
impact statement is after the trial is
over after the verdict so it's a
statement given on not given under oath
well after the trial you're saying she
also didn't test you think she's lying
essentially I mean or at least there'd
be no consequence to her lying right
that's my point I'm not here to debate
whether or not yeah I get it but you
know what's crazy what I'm saying is
okay go ahead yeah I'm just saying it's
important that we live if we want to
live in a society that has due process
and we care about Justice it's important
to question absolutely it's important to
question and my point is if somebody
gives a victim impact statement and says
I was raped and this happened I'm not
saying that's not true but you can't say
that that's ultimately true due process
when someone's not unsure for sure there
was no trial and so that's
so that's my point what I do there's no
trial like I was supposed to take her
impact statement seriously when there's
no trial
that is my point okay what I do know
which is under oath and uh you know
sworn statements is what I got in touch
with you about with respect to we now
have seven digital forensic experts and
this is what's incredible four of those
seven
four of the seven oh I'm sorry
FBI before we go down that thread I just
wanted to mention and I don't know if
this is an issue for you guys but there
was 15 other Victim Impact statements
from all different individuals so that's
like dang how do we get over that
okay again there's if we had like a
three hour podcast I can go into
different things this is the short of it
though just to give an answer like I
said uh my intent wasn't to try to uh
defend or combat like all these
different allegations but right right
again
what people don't realize the way that
the narrative was out there is that 17
000 people 17 000 people from around the
world took these courses okay
one in 400 of participants in the
classes that Keith had created were
billionaires we had people from Stanford
from Harvard uh entrepreneurs these were
very thoughtful rational people taking
courses
right I mean Scientology is the same way
and they get vilified too they have tons
of famous people tons of rich people and
it's unfair that Scientology is vilified
don't you think
I haven't taken Scientology I don't
agree with yeah but well no but my point
is I don't agree with character
assassination
um you know or speaking badly about a
group just because they're different or
you don't like them
but Okay the reason I mentioned about
the 17 000 is is that if you actually
look at the trial in the Nexium trial
there's actually out of 17 000 people I
think in the trial don't take my word
for it I think there's only three people
that were students
of the 17 000 that were even claiming uh
they were victims of a crime so the only
so three out of seven thousand people
claimed that they were molested by Keith
well no they weren't even claiming that
they were molested there's not even this
is what I this is like the the insanity
and the the exaggeration of what's out
there right the there's not a single
charge of Keith assaulting or raping or
or hurting anyone uh means of violence
there's nothing there's nothing in the
trial of that right there's no violence
they're only they're only saying he
coerced them but that's not really a
crime is it
well that's what they're claiming but
right my point is is that if you want to
look at the reality if you even want to
say that everything that happened in the
trial is true yeah this is a man who's
now convicted and sentenced to 120 years
without any violence weapons drugs right
and total and I'm with you 100 because
coercion's not even a crime like you can
it's not illegal to manipulate people
this just means you're smarter
so again and this is a whole
conversation about you know things in
the trial right but the bigger issue the
the the thing that is I think
vital and uh relevant to everyone who's
lit you know listens to you and then
also just all you know citizens in the
United States we now have four former
FBI agents that were digital forensic
experts that have come out that under
sworn testimony shows that the child
pornography evidence was to a scientific
certainty tampered with and also planted
that is very evidence points and some of
the evidence points that some of those
uh some of the modifications took place
while in the possession of the FBI that
is very concerning so what is the um
so what's the goal here to get a retrial
for Keith
well part well the ultimate goal is
trying to investigate
um these crimes right there's clear
probable Beyond probable cause that that
crimes were committed by FBI agents and
potentially even the prosecution and
maybe
um other entities with other entities as
well in the doj and that is an effective
that yeah because the because crimes
were committed
against uh someone who is being tried in
a trial to convict them right that
person should ultimately be let free let
him free and so Keith free Keith
well what's interesting is that
first of all the FBI is a criminal
organization just from the start I mean
it's insane the things that they've done
to people like tampering evidence in the
kiss of Keith
but I think that because they did that
we should probably just expunge the
extortion the identity theft the forced
labor
the conspiracy to commit identity theft
exploiting of a child forced labor
wire fraud and uh and so we should we
should expunge all those huh
it took me a second to get your humor
because like there's also a little delay
I was like is he making a joke I was
like oh I know I know sorry I just uh
yeah but so like what do we do about
those other ones right because like we
got to convince everyone that Keith is
like a cool dude
uh well this is what I'm saying is is
that we don't need to convince anyone of
how cool he is
um someone can can think that Keith
Rainier
um they can believe he's the devil
that's um that's ultimately irrelevant
and a distraction to the reality of did
this person receive due process if we
want to leave it live in a society
that we want to have a justice system
that treats
everyone exactly the same whether you
think someone is the devil or you think
someone is Mr Rogers they should be
treated exactly the same under the law
now if it's the case that the government
actually had evidence on Keith or Neri
then the question then becomes well why
would they need to fabricate and tamper
with evidence right right that is the
question free Keith
actually I want to talk I want us to
answer oh go ahead you I wanted to ask
you about your last thing sure go ahead
go ahead
I just want to just make one other
comments because you said as I know you
were you were being facetious about all
these other charges yeah yeah if you act
again there's you know these these
buzzwords of sex trafficking and forced
labor yes those are on it face value
sound horrific right but what it what
does it even mean
exactly like when you think of you know
if you heard that you're you know
someone that you know got charged with
sex trafficking what would you imagine
yeah I would imagine somebody was locked
to a you know a a uh uh uh what do you
call yeah walk to a radiator doing
forced to do like webcam work or you
know what I mean exactly yeah yeah
that's what and that's a real that by
the way is a real thing
sex trafficking people being kidnapped
forced into sex slavery is a real thing
if you actually look at the evidence of
what happened in this trial you have a
29 year old female who is an actress
living in Manhattan who is a part of the
Nexium Community she was taking classes
she was in a relationship with Keith She
also had a history of being more kinky
together they had come up with with an
experience where uh and this is
literally if you look at the transcripts
this is what happened one woman this 29
year old received oral sex from another
woman and no money was exchanged
she took a bus from Brooklyn to Albany
right and they convicted Keith of sex
trafficking just because she was kinky
well that's one way to look at it right
the same woman the 29 year old actress
she's also the victim of the alleged
forced labor this is a woman who had to
transcribe five hours of video for a
memorial and she read 50 articles that
Keith had written and she gave feedback
on them and actually loved reading them
he was convicted of forced labor because
because she wasn't paid for her work or
what
oh that's what they were claiming they
were able to concoct she was 29 years
old my point is is that right totally
there's what's in the media which isn't
and of course if you hear these words
it's not like I don't hear these things
forced labor sex trafficking and it
caused me to have ocean and I'm like
holy crap what happened here but this
one sounds really bad and hopefully
because you on you have such an intimate
understanding and you have a great way
of explaining it so how do we do the
exploit sexual exploitation of a child
because that one sounds so bad so how do
we break that one down
that one is also related to the the
child pornography as I said so they
found 22 photos of a naked woman now by
looking at the photos is not how they
realized
he knew right it was a girl it was girls
he knew yeah yeah these are women that
he knew yeah and so someone somebody had
pictures of them naked when they were
kids
but it wasn't Keith well
no but this is no just if I could just
finish real quick is that the 22 photos
were not deemed child pornography
because they were photos of some sexual
act the way that they deemed their child
pornography was based was based off of
the file dates and based off of the file
dates they then said when the photos
were taken is when this person they
probably didn't even look like kids in
the picture
that's what I'm say that's my point is
is that by looking at the photo they
weren't deemed traffic and I mean if you
saw the photo which you you should get a
hold of those photos they probably look
like I have not seen adults
I have not seen the photos oh you have
those are you know those are Contraband
photos right but my point is is that
again when you hear the word child
pornography it incites you know all
these horrible images and fears but what
we're talking about is on an ex not out
on someone's computer not on their
camera not on a camera card in a random
external hard drive there's 22 photos
right
um of a naked woman who they deemed this
is underage because of the file dates so
just though the last thing is the sexual
exploitation of a minor is because
supposedly they were able to link
through a media card and from a camera
and that media card to a scientific
certainty by seven digital forensic
experts four former FBI was modified
while in the possession of the FBI
because they were able to link that
media card to a camera that's allegedly
keithoned that's how he was charged with
sexual exploitation so ridiculous that
like that's all they need
wait I don't know if I don't know if
you're being no I'm dead serious like
what the [__] like it's scary the world
we live in where
like
and people can just say whatever and
then like oh you just change the data on
a file card and that's all it takes
it's crazy it's scary as a man I'm
scared of that
everyone should be scared of this this
is why the reason we're trying to reach
out to people is because the narrative
is so strong and the prejudice against
Keith and Nexium is so intense is that
basically it stops people from having a
rational open conversation but wait a
minute what actually took place here and
what took place here is not just oh
there was some Prejudice in a trial is
that clearly you have government actors
specific
um Personnel in the FBI and again this
is not an attack on the whole FBI
actually there's one thing you want to
get your thoughts on here uh so
Camilla's the one who he apparently had
photos of
that was the 15 year old girl who did an
impact statement or she you know she did
an impact statement said that he took
her virginity when she was 15 which is
outrageous I mean
you can't the thing is you can't
you can't I
she if she was willing what's the
problem I I don't get it but anyway
right you're like you understand that
again right whether or not that happened
or it did not assault if she liked it
and Keith is awesome
I'm starting yeah I'm feeling your humor
a little bit more like I said there's a
little delay as well
um so Camilla I just want to be so
Camilla super clear again I don't I I
don't support sexual assault rape in any
way yeah I'm not here to be able to uh
uh be a referee about what he said or
she said or what happened behind closed
doors what I do know is that I don't
believe that somebody giving a victim
impact statement that isn't under oath
which is basically no different from
somebody going on Twitter and saying I
was raped by this person right with
absolutely no due process right because
he looked at he doesn't even know them
so it's like the same as a random tweet
like they've never even met
they do know but they do know each other
they do know each other but do you
understand what I'm saying yeah no
absolutely so Rainier is so this girl
Camille who she said in her impact
statement that
um Ranieri and his co-conspirator who
also traffic Daniella for labor and
services said they can find her to a
hotel room or to a room sorry for nearly
two years in an attempt to force
Daniella to work for him and then
Daniela was told that if she left the
room she would be sent to Mexico without
any identifying documents so that's
probably what they mean by like sex
trafficking or or forced labor but
that's just someone on Twitter just
making [__] up
well again did you see the second season
of The Vow no I didn't watch the second
season was that yeah gotcha I I don't I
don't blame you
um yeah yeah it's it's incredible again
if yes from just the the label of
somebody you know I think it's document
servitude that sounds horrible right but
if
but again if you just look at the facts
this is a young girl who's staying and
who is in a room in her family's home
okay like her family's she was in a room
and the door wasn't locked right and if
anyone questions me on that this is
incredible this is how uh amazing how a
documentary can can seemingly put eerie
music on something and make it horrific
right in the documentary they're
actually doing a voiceover of her
reading like uh from her lines uh from
the the court transcript so they're
reading it verbatim from what she said
in quarter she was testifying under oath
and at the very end of this episode as
she's talking about how she's been
confined to this room for two years
right do you know how the scene ends how
she says and then I walked out of the
room oh because she could have left the
whole time they don't they don't really
be because she couldn't
of course but it's you know it's the
scary music and It's haunting and this
illustrations and the cartoon and it's
but the way that it's in the media it
sounds as if some that you know Keith or
Neri you know what I cannot understand I
understand I'm in a room yeah yeah I
want to ask you and that's that is the
issue of you know again of why I reached
out is is that in the media can do
whatever they want and paint anyone uh
you know with with whatever colors they
want to create a certain image and that
does not necessarily match the reality
of even just basic facts because it's
basically her fault for not leaving the
room and what's even crazier is that the
whole jury basically like how did like
they all got I don't know how the whole
Jerry agreed on that but I want to ask
you about your experience with Tourette
Syndrome I'm super super fascinated by
this
um
this is so so this is why kind of Nexium
is is kind of interesting because
everyone always just kind of sees like
the the bad side that's what's famous
now but Nexium actually has been helping
people in these incredible ways
for example you had debilitating
Tourette's Syndrome right
and then I think you joined Nexium and
Keith was able to
to to help you overcome it totally like
totally cured like
your Tourette's is 100 gone
so yes the answer is I no longer have
Tourette Syndrome wow and it was through
the courses that Keith created it wasn't
even one-on-one sessions with anything
he was you know he had created a
curriculum that had was around the world
like I said 17 000 people took it I went
through the classes just like everybody
else but as I went through them and
started to build more self-awareness
about myself I mean ultimately the
courses are and our classes on uh
emotional intelligence you know we we
had a center here in New York City on
Seventh uh Fifth and 37th Street you
know where it's just you go and sit in
chairs and you have conversations with
people and that that is just that just
having that it's going to be clear it's
not go ahead yes it was through through
these conversations and through these
classes which were a lot of them were
philosophical inquiries about different
aspects of Life there were practical
things it was also a goal-setting thing
for entrepreneurs and it was through
these classes and these conversations
that beat my Tourette's completely mind
over body wow and so what is it that you
tell yourself like ah just stopped
ticking like come on don't be a [__] or
whatever
or I know I'm joking I don't mean it
like that but like uh I'm [__] I'm over
this [__] sucks tourettes is [__]
annoying and I'm just over it
yeah so it's uh it's not like that at
all uh the the most simple way that I
can describe it is that I I've always
talked about Tourette's is like there's
an itch and there's a scratch oh yeah
and the Tourette's is that uncomfortable
feeling and then the the ticking is me
scratching that itch and most uh most uh
treatments and the way that we look at
Tourette's is you know okay how do we
just help the person with this Dynamic
so if you take medication it numbs the
itch so that stops you from wanting to
scratch it because
if you're talking to someone with
Tourette's syndrome
how would you what would kind of be your
advice to them because I know it's just
a horrible disease for the people who
haven't cured it for themselves yet and
I feel like this yeah yeah what would
what would be your advice well I don't
say just to be clear I've never said and
so we actually had a documentary that
came out it's called My Tourette's it's
on YouTube for free now okay
um sadly almost no one in the world
knows about it it came out after
um you know the the negative press the
real negative press uh started coming
out about five years ago but in this
documentary you you watch this these
profound transformations of people
beating Tourette's mind over body but
even in the movie we don't say secure
this is not we didn't have a cure for
Tourette's clearly we had a set of tools
for people that were open and wanted to
go on a different type of Journey you
know go on more of a uh looking inward
but you guys did good for some you said
it's 100 gone I mean let's not beat
around the bush that sounds like I just
don't say the reason I don't say cure is
because also I just don't think of it as
something that you can cure in that way
I like a completely different I don't
even think of it as a medical disorder
in that way now but what I just want to
be super clear is that it's I don't know
if I don't know if it could help
everyone I don't know that the people
that we helped wanted to be helped if
someone wants to lose weight they could
have the best trainer in the whole world
but if they don't want to lose weight
but wait
yeah but being fat is not a neurological
disorder so that's what really interests
me because accordingly because to all
the literature it says Tourette's cannot
be
cannot be cured
I I so it's incredible reaching to the
choir yeah right I lived with it for 20
I I for 20 years I became a well-known
inspirational speaker around the country
talking about Tourette's living with
Tourette's my whole life was based off
of Tourette's I can't imagine how hard I
get in it was uh you know so then to to
take a class on emotions and now to be
able to have a conversation with you
like this
I couldn't even have dreamed of it I
mean it just wasn't even something that
could be possible because of like like
what you said I have Tourette's this
neurological genetic disorder that's
involuntary and has no cure
luckily because of the of what Keith
created and with Nancy Salzman who also
was in jail now uh
I've been able to go on on a profound uh
journey to live a very different life
can I ask you a question answer your
question do you still get the urge to do
ticks or is that completely gone like
where did you cut it off so the that the
the thing about the itch in the scratch
because of how the courses were very
different it's not like I'm sitting here
and my itch is a hundred percent and I'm
just like okay don't tick don't say
don't say something you know and hold it
back right the the courses were
different than any other thing that I
did is because by going on that
exploration
I found out that that my itch was way
more emotional and psychological than it
was physiological and as a result
and working internal issues I had anger
stuff
um beliefs about all this sorts of stuff
as a result of that my itch went down so
right now do I still have an itch yeah
it's not at zero but it's probably yeah
four out of a hundred okay okay okay so
but so to call that Tourette's is that I
I don't even think of it as Tourette's I
think of it as I I'm a person that has a
body and all of us have uncomfortable
things and what I I come to understand
and this is for me is that ultimately I
was in a sense had an Impulse disorder
that doesn't mean I had a neurological
disorder I found this as a work thing or
this old video of you I found really
compelling from 14 years ago
do you mind if I watch real fast for the
audience just to kind of give you
absolutely background yeah so this is
from absolutely this was 14 years ago
from a
um local news story or something like
that right the covered your story
yeah I was yes
and did you yeah so okay let me watch it
oh sorry sorry I thought you were about
to press play
oh yeah no I'm gonna press play right
now okay
are you okay if I press play
oh yeah sorry I thought you were you
were hitting it okay
can you play it Dan
um
are you ready mark
I'm ready okay a day before my 17th
birthday is when I really ran into the
greatest obstacle I had ever encountered
with my Tourette Syndrome uh St Louis
area a teenager who says he has Tourette
Syndrome claims he was kicked off a
Greyhound bus in Indianapolis because of
his disability
I got on the bus and uh they made an
announcement about my Tourette syndrome
and uh earlier in line a lady had heard
me saying some inappropriate words
and she stood up and she said well how
come he can say this word with that this
Clayton High Junior who turned 17
tomorrow says he was kicked off the bus
in Indianapolis so you were Europe tick
was actually to say the N word right
yeah different times I was saying what
would be the worst thing that I could
possibly say in a given moment so you
know if I was around a fat person I
would want to take your fat if I was
around a black person I would want to
take the N word so yeah at the time it
was a nightmare at the time you were on
a bus and with it seems like from this
image predominantly black and then you
said the n-word on the bus
yeah to make a long story short I had
told the bus driver about my Tourette's
before I got on and then I got on the
bus then I was taking it more and
obviously customers were complaining and
rightfully so I mean they had no idea
what was going on
and then the bus driver you know
they you know as I've gotten older I
actually thought the bus the company
dealt with it as well as they could you
know um I mean it's just a difficult
situation I mean just because it's a
medical disorder although I don't see it
the same way now but of course at the
time
you know what do you do you know it's
just not I don't think it's as simple as
oh well this person has a disability
they just have you know can do whatever
they want carte blanche like it's a very
difficult thing because I'm also saying
something that's offending people
luckily nothing bad happened you know I
I was safe it could have it could have
escalated and gotten very bad so you
went so did you okay so let me keep
watching so you're on a bus and you said
the n-word and then people got mad at
you right so so that's the kind of sure
so let me keep watching and ultimately
after Elliott says he was on his way
home from a church youth camp when the
incident happened Elliot and his family
say they've traveled all over the
country and never been denied access to
Transportation his family calls it a
violation of the Americans with
Disabilities Act up to that point so do
you so I so I I appreciate that you guys
all made it until I kind of turned it
into like a crusade here and went to the
local news about it and stuff because
it's
let me I have a theory for you
I'm ready okay cool
I think you actually fake having turrets
yeah I don't think I think you actually
don't have it
well but I'm open to it there's my guy
what did you think I had well let me
just break it down I think
this is kind of a funny thing I doubt
this is what happened but maybe you're
just on maybe you just called someone
the n-word on the bus and then you're
like oh no I have Tourette's because
what's interesting to me and I know
that's funny
but what's interesting to me is that
you've made like a whole career being a
motivational speaker about how you cured
your Tourette's and stuff and that's
kind of become like a big part of your
identity but what's interesting is as
somebody with Tourette's I actually have
Tourette's I know it's not curable so I
just find that claim to be absolutely a
pseudo-scientific crazy claim that has
no backing in science or at all and I
think you're actually uh in my opinion
right as as someone with Tourette's I
think you're scamming people
well first off I did you say that you
have Tourette's I do have Tourette's I
didn't know the crazy yeah I know that's
why I was so surprised when you emailed
me because I was like I was like I have
Tourette's
and I also [__] hate Andrew Tay I've
like talked like continually and openly
relentlessly about what a piece of [__]
he is and how much I hate him and what's
interesting too
Mark is that I've also talked about how
much I hate Keith and Nexium and what a
psycho he is so when I got your email I
was like this is incredible and I could
totally see how it is you fell into a
into a cold because you clearly don't do
any research
you know when I saw the uh when I was
watching one of your videos I I thought
I saw you ticking
and so I I it did cross my mind I said I
wonder if he has Tourette's yeah I do
why would you that's so interesting why
would you
why would you think someone would fake
it that's a pretty messed up thing for
someone to fake no I agree but you've
made a good living from Faking It doing
like motivational stuff and and
spreading books and stuff like that and
it's just as far as I know and that's
just a theory right because I don't know
I mean I just have Tourette's myself but
obviously I don't know anything about
you so it's just a theory but I just
think that you can't cure it actually
and on your website it says you overcame
it mind over body and that's just not
possible
but that's why I don't know if you
remember what I just said two minutes
ago is that we've never claimed it's a
cure
right well on let's see let's see on the
if we pull up your website well when I
when I started you said you're 100 like
over Tourette's right you did say that
yeah I said that I don't think of it as
I I have Tourette's anymore right I
don't have it anymore I guess just I
guess what I could say is
um
foreign
yeah the fact that you don't like Tate
and you don't like Ranieri is not a
reason that I couldn't talk to someone
if anything it's about that's not the
point of trying to find right people
that love him it's if you can find
people
even if somebody hates someone the
question is do we believe that there
should be due process in this country
and are we okay with government
officials or FBI agents committing
crimes to convict a man
yeah yeah
but somebody not liking him is if if if
anything is is definitely better
um I definitely did not research deeply
every single person obviously yeah you
know you didn't look you actually didn't
look and do it at all
like the most basic but let me break it
down mark because in a way I see you as
well just to be just to be hold on just
to be very okay guys to be very blunt go
ahead go ahead yeah be blind yeah I you
are right I did not do research yeah my
someone that I know who's Keith
currently he's been sitting in the shoe
for over 200 days so they're basically
torturing a U.S citizen while the same
time he has filed in the eastern
district of New York with four former
FBI agents showing that the FBI
tampered with digital evidence and
they're now uh escalating the torture
and they might ship him to what's known
as a CMU can I read a contributions can
I read an excerpt for you it says do you
this is from your website this is your
website right Mark elliott.com
yep yeah do you want to beat your
Tourette's I want to help you but
currently the government has threatened
to put me in jail for being public about
how I completely overcame my Tourette's
with Nexium
yep so when you say completely overcame
I just assumed that meant like that you
have a cure
for it yeah we just I can I can address
that in a second we can talk about that
but the point is is that can you cure
like Bible or something can you cure
like schizophrenia because that would be
really good for a lot of people the
reason so because of how big the case is
right and I'm reaching out to people
that have influence I believe that even
though you might hate those people and I
didn't know I didn't know the depth of
how much you disliked them but yeah okay
yeah is that there's something that we
can agree upon I thought at least here's
something are we okay well we can all
agree on that we can all agree on photos
here's photos of his initials being
branded into women who accused him of
running a
clandestine sex cult here is his
initials branded into their skin
here's an up close for you it says it
says his initial Keith Rainier is
branded into the skin
what what is your what's what's your
point that's not what I'm here to talk
to you about oh my point
um
that the thing is also the point is you
know that was just for fun that was just
like a funsies thing
yeah but this is just like a fun little
group building exercise
no I'm serious I'm serious why do you
why did he do this because if I'm
curious I want to ask you the thing is
if you're gonna if you're going if
you're gonna say things they need to be
fair they're just kinky little kinky
but Keith Ranieri didn't brand anyone oh
right he's not even in the room who
coerced people yeah so coercion
I think coercion is a crime sex
trafficking usually happens through
coercion not by Red locking people to a
radiator so that I think is where we
kind of Disconnect there and actually
what's crazy you agreed with me 12
people I agreed I had told you before I
know I had told you before crime oh
what's crazy is he appealed and then the
appeals court also
upheld these seven horrific charges
against him
so that's like a lot I wasn't here
yeah that's a lot of people like I had
said I'm
I had said to you in the very beginning
as is that I believe most of things are
not true out there that doesn't mean
there isn't kernels of truth I wanted to
talk to you about something that I think
is greater than Keith Ranieri the fact
that we have evidence that shows that
the FBI committed crime yeah but the FBS
I agree with you that the FBI is shitty
and they do that kind of stuff but even
if we discount everything the FBI
allegedly uh or you say they let's just
assume for the sake of this conversation
that
they did do that then you still have to
explain
all these other charges
like even if he's not even if he didn't
have child pornography on a hard drive
right and let's just say he didn't do it
it was a conspiracy we don't or maybe
they changed the metadata there's still
racketeering forced labor wire fraud
sex trafficking
extortion
so do you have a do you know what I mean
so they're kind of an issue here well
we've been the thing is look I I this is
the first time we've ever met Ethan yeah
um
I said to you in the email of that if
you want to have more of an open
rational conversation or we can
challenge things in the first half of
this I talked to you about some of the
facts that it sounds like you were
agreeing with I didn't realize that you
were just trying to play me I the things
that I said I stand by I don't need to
change anything even though now I know
that I guess you were trying to have
sort of a gotcha moment but like I said
with the photos with the woman the HBO
thing the sex trafficking which is a
single sex act with no money exchange
these are things that yeah but if
somebody wants to have a conversation
right but you got to understand that no
money exchanged and him not doing it
himself is kind of the quintessential
of a uh
a cultish kind of racketeering like
manipulative coercive act like he's not
the first person right like Charles
Manson for example does Charles is
Charles Manson guilty of murder well
answer that is Charles Manson guilty
murder he never did anything
I don't know nothing I don't okay I'll
explain it to you I'll explain it to you
Charles Manson people say he was a
member of a cult his disciples went
under his uh order or coercion to go and
murder this family right and so his
lawyer said well he didn't do anything
he wasn't even there and so the question
is
do you think Charles Manson is guilty
who's in jail right now for for being
involved in their murders even though he
wasn't there he never held a knife in
his hand you know what I mean no money
was exchanged they didn't even get he
didn't even pay them to do it
I have oh he's dead that's a correction
let me issue a factual correction no
this is this is what I would say I don't
know anything about the case obviously I
know of Charles Manson because of you
know of How It's been you know he's uh
he's probably innocent too right
well I don't know but what I do believe
what I'm absolutely will stand by is
that I do think no matter how hated a
person is we should be absolutely open
to questioning narratives we should be
able to question
um I think Partners we should be able I
think part of a Redemption of accepting
people who are bad starts with them you
know coming to terms with what they've
done
but that's what I said from the from the
get-go I said I'm not on here to try to
get you to like Keith Ranieri you can I
don't know if you remember I did say I
did say to you you can think he's the
devil I don't think he's the dude
remember when I said that no but no but
my point is someone wants to believe
that so you're saying we need to that's
not what you're saying we need to take
the time to look at the kind of the
facts and the situations and come to
like you know just with our whole hearts
and Minds come to a rational decision
well my question too is that's a trial I
believe that there are due to trial but
there are certainly lost two of them
do you believe that it is okay under any
circumstance for the government or
government officials whether it's a
prosecutor whether it's a judge whether
it's an FB agent to commit a crime to
convict of course no never
mind good if we agree on that Ethan yeah
if you and I can agree on that yeah
that's all that matters and that's why
I'm here
significant
like like I mean we can both agree that
Crispy Donuts are great tastes great but
that doesn't really have anything that
doesn't have nothing to do with like
wire fraud and racketeering
why do you believe that that's not
significant
because it doesn't it doesn't
affect all the other unrelated crimes he
was convicted of but no
no the part where we're just missing is
that you keep making it about this case
what I'm saying is what I'm addressing
affects every single case this is bigger
than Keith
yeah Keith is not bigger than the
justice system if you allow or you are
okay permitting government officials to
commit crimes to convict even a hated
person what you ultimately are saying is
that you believe that prejudice and hate
are more important than Justice
here's you and Keith
he has really nice skin [__]
the thing is he has you do I'm trying to
have a I'm trying to have no I'm trying
to have a serious conversation no I was
just struck by his really nice skin did
he ever drop I'm just saying I
I'm just saying out of respect I'm
trying to have a a conversation with you
about something that affects millions of
people around the Justice you know
millions of people in the justice system
and are affected by our justice system
this isn't about Keith it is about Keith
because this is the specific case and
the specific evidence that we have do
you mind if I take a moment and read
some of the quotes from the FBI agents
uh uh no I don't want to do that let me
ask you this I don't even blame you
because honestly in a sense you're i s
you're kind of the victim of uh you're
you know what I mean like you're part of
this organization that clearly has some
powerful hold over you and I'm I'm
really sorry that you got somehow you're
involved in this and I just like Keith
is gone he can't hurt you anymore
you know what I mean like you're free
bro
I I I appreciate the uh I I do believe
that I'm free I'm an adult that makes
decisions just like that girl in the
room you're free man just walk through
the door
well what I can say again is I reached
out to you
um I'm trying to talk about things that
there's a lot of prejudice against
talking about you have a case that has
International attention it has a lot of
hate and a lot of people and now we have
that we keep it we're kind of you've
said that it's okay listen
um I want I really do wish the best for
you and I'm sorry that you're dealing
with all this stuff it seems like you're
going through a lot and
I just you know I'm sorry man I just I
don't know if there's anything you know
they might do they have photos of you
like like they must have because that
was their thing right Keith had like
blackmail there's no photos I just yeah
for for anyone who's listening that
wants to find out more they can go to
make justicesblind.com and they can look
at the evidence with respect
with respect to the FBI and you know
what I've been talking about actually
here this this is the video right uh
evidence of historic FBI corruption this
is the one you're talking about could we
at least could we at least one of the
guys is Alan dershowitz
he's Epstein's lawyer
could could we play it from the
beginning
you know what I'll do you know what
I'll do that for you we've been through
a lot together I'll play you the dersh
well no couldn't no no I'm saying can
you play it from the beginning which is
the experts which is actually what's
most important well he is in this video
so I'm assuming he's an expert no but
he's he's under the section of advocates
in the beginning of the two minute video
there's the whole section on Experts
it's only two minutes I'd be grateful if
you play that at least an advocate
okay cool yeah this alleged FBI
malfeasance turns out to be true as our
experts say it is then this is really
historic this is really an attempt to
frame somebody based on manipulation of
data that's just
unacceptable in an American court and in
the American legal system I'm the former
United he's the man bro Alan dursh but
the thing is is there a reason you can't
play it from the beginning I'm afraid
that it's compelling frankly I don't
want no I will play it I'll play it I'll
play it so these people
um
yeah that so these These are we just
have these are all former FBI people who
okay I'm gonna play some of them are
former I owe that to you yeah I owe that
too I'm gonna play it I'm gonna play it
awesome experts versus Keith
I worked in the FBI for about 10 years
10-year clear
were planted there this is the most
serious how did they get the photos to
examine because there's apparently child
pornography on the photos it seems kind
of like a hot potato
and um
and I hesitate to call pictures of John
Murphy a hot potato you know they're not
looking at no one's looking at pictures
of chalkboard it's there's they're
looking at metadata files the file data
tampering of evidence that I've ever
seen it's inescapable that the FBI
proactively created fake evidence
FBI custody uh it was modified it was
altered in 25 years of the cheers
the amount of technical ability and
premeditation to perform this fraud in
the case against Mr Ranieri I've never
seen anything like that in my 20 years
experience with the FBI I have never
seen
data manipulation evidence tampering
anything like this on this scale
when I first read the papers that Mr
rainieri presented on tampering I was
shocked I've never seen an instance
where the
threw away is credibility purely for the
purpose of convicting
if it could happen to a person who was
educated who was white who has the
complexion for acceptance as I would say
none of us are safe there's no need to
fabricate evidence for a guilty man the
fact that they fabricated evidence here
and to the degree that they did
[Music]
if this alleged FBI malfeasance turns
out to be true as our experts say it is
and this is really historic this is
really an attempt to frame somebody
based on manipulation of data that's
just
unacceptable
in the American legal system I'm the
former United States Attorney for the
eastern district
in the face of this alarming evidence
there's really no excuse
things
if an independent investigation
determines that this campaign occurred
there must be accountability
prosecuted this is very serious okay
yeah
shortly after Mr renner's legal team
first exposed this corruption the
government retaliated
yeah I mean I mean what I I know that
you were playing the music which was
unfortunate in making the jokes you know
these are people whether or not again
whether you hate Keith bruneria or
whatever you think about Nexium you know
these are very people that have served
our country those are uh four FBI agents
other distinguished experts there's also
a former U.S prosecutor
um
you know again if you don't want to hear
that you know okay I'm here's what I I
just want to
I'm gonna give you whatever here's what
I want to do wait um I want to give you
the platform I'm just going to step away
because listen obviously we've been
doing some Goofs here and I feel I owe
it to you I'm going to step away I'm
gonna sit right here and listen but I'm
not going to interrupt you I'm just
going to let you say your thing I'm I'm
sorry
go ahead
all I'll say is first thank you again
for uh you know allowing me to come on I
didn't appreciate sort of the way it
went but even with that
what I'm talking about today and the
video that you saw with these experts
these are serious serious things that
we're talking about
I think I think that's uh
what's wrong what happened well thank
you yeah
do you want to give a closing statement
or anything
no I think that they're just putting
things on the screen oh it's just no
that helps people's attention span
because it's a little boring so it's a
little dense so sometimes we put kinetic
sand or Subway Surfer it makes it easier
to listen
gotcha thank you for having me this
photo of you guys a video Three Amigos
did you I'm with you by the way acap
brother
[Laughter]
you don't know how to turn off Zoom
you're trying but you can't get away
yeah
how do we how do you get out of this
no there's no trouble well again nice to
meet you Ethan and uh yeah hi thanks for
having me on I'm sorry I'm sorry to put
you all through that ultimately you are
the victim and I hope Rainier's dies
version I really do
I really do but one day you're gonna be
free of this and I'll be there to help
you I'm so sorry you this is Keith's
fault that you went through this it
really is and I'm so sorry
yeah thanks for having me on today yeah
thank you for joining us
all right take care have a good night
have a good night thank you
oh God
he hung up yeah I know
I actually feel bad for him at the end
there yeah but to me it's extremely
embarrassing but to be completely fair
this man will walk into like a comet
sized Chasm yeah of a death trap you can
turn back on chat all right I'll turn it
back on
like when I got this email from him that
I read you guys I was like is this guy
for real and so I pass it to Dan to set
it up and sure enough this guy
thought I was an Andrew Tate Defender
who loves
[__] Keith Ramirez and also he didn't
know I have Tourette Syndrome which put
me in kind of a unique position to
talk to him about Tourette's
um and that was a very stressful
situation I did see him take it once
just saying
must be effective
I'm sorry I honestly feel bad I do feel
bad he he that man is crushed but you
know what at the end of the day
definitely do a tiny bit of research for
calling into one of the biggest podcasts
in the world to do a live show about one
of the most hated men in the world I
will say I really admire your ability to
continue to be confrontational
throughout an entire exchange like at
some point I was like oh man like is he
gonna is he gonna like
loosen up a bit and you no no and I mean
I stand by what you you did I I love
that I could not let him spread
propaganda unchecked yeah I'll tell you
what if his Tourette's was cured it's
definitely coming back after this
interview
I'm gonna be screaming the N word all
night
oh my God that was CR that was like as
crazy as I hoped that could have been
that was
that was clean yeah I really wasn't sure
what direction was going to go I mean we
were talking about before the show but I
still was unsure if he was uh I'm Blown
Away being sarcastic in his email
because it was just so
wrong about every aspect and then of you
right that it almost seemed like sarcasm
so I really I thought he was going to
come out of the gate aggressive but no
he seemed to just not actually research
anything at all
like even just a Google search
bro you didn't even know you had
Tourette's yes I know he didn't even but
like if you search my name it's probably
like all hides the lights of me talking
[__] on Andrew Tate and I've done so
much content about Nexium
that too
oh
holy [__] dude I don't think I've ever
seen someone get cooked like that my
whole life
that was you know all this Victory right
there I had to walk away so you can yeah
I walked yeah for a sec there one point
when I was reading out every like every
20 charges I was like this is so absurd
and he he took him a long time and he
was hesitant to accept the fact that he
that I was goofing
you ate him up and you
left no crumbs there you go he's
learning he's learning clearly he sees
the best in people so yeah
I mean I'm glad you said what you said
about him being a victim in a way
because I mean that's it I felt pretty
bad
Stockholm syndrome kind of thing in 30
years from now you're gonna get emails
saying dude I [__] up I'm sorry about
that I'll be there with open arms yeah
sure I'm waiting for him
[Music]
we even got the Subway Surfer on him
dude and the a Nook I mean that was
something else man when he saw the
Manson photo my heart dropped a little
bit he he made a very sad face when he
saw that well I don't think he Three
Amigos he said he didn't know anything
about Charles Manson well he's lying
well he knew something he saw that
[__] photo he knows about Charles
Manson right everybody does
enough you know what I mean sure
he does have beautiful skin though Keith
I was like whoa
you must use like uh
what's that serum that's really popular
adrenochrome no not that one
whatever you must use the ordinary
and I was like well they have a great
product doesn't matter they do wonderful
hyaluronic acid
you know
[__] me dude
uh you know this guy it seems like he's
a he seems very nice and well uh you
know pretty well spoken articulate and
his heart seems good yeah and uh you
know he's a good looking guy and
everything it's just that's why I mean
it's just like a little sad it's just
White
why do you feel the need to die on this
hill like can you even if you even if
you think that Keith is innocent like
making that your thing to like campaign
for like he's interconnected
sex that's why I thought it was
interesting you asked him out the photos
and maybe he doesn't have any blackmail
over him so Nexium is well known
for holding dirt or blackmail yeah
make sure they stay in line right
and um he's it and he's in a quote I
mean it's the same way scientologists
will like
follow people with cameras and [__]
abuse them Relentless they're convinced
they're right and it's the whole world
that's wrong and uh I'm it sucks man but
when you have Titans like Alan
dershowitz on your side you know your
dubs all around the dersh baby
I can't believe he's in that video I'm a
jog drop
of course he is that man's willing to
defend goddamn Adolf Hitler he has never
seen a pedophile that he wouldn't defend
right Alan dershowitz
and I mean there's it's just so much
stacked against Keith he has a 120 years
and I'm like
he seems to be singularly focused on the
FBI tampering So I says okay let's even
give you that I mean still this man is a
prolific criminal even without that
and then he seems to think it's all if I
was understanding him correctly it
seemed like if you you take out this one
piece this one photo of a 15 year old
girl the whole thing collapses which
like it's just not I'm not I didn't
follow the case super closely but when I
was researching I researched quite a bit
over the weekend it just familiarize
myself with everything and um
at least from my understanding of it the
whole metadata aspect is not
The Smoking Gun that got him convicted
so even if you remove that they got a
retrial and they removed that I'm pretty
certain they would still be able to find
a second well they had 15 victims
statements this girl who was in the
photos Camille who says that he took her
Virginia when she was 15 who was in
those photos
said it was him right yeah or at least I
think so I mean I can read this well
there's more too there's I didn't
there's a bunch I don't know if he said
it was him or not I don't I know he's
gonna try to sue me if anything a little
thing wait said it was who
Camille was the girl who was in the
photos the child P right yes yeah and
she gave a victim impact yeah
yeah no I mean according to her she was
groomed from like age 12 and that in
Keith Rainier took her virginity when
she was underage so and he seems to
think that like co-work like the fact
that he
coerced people and never actually
carried out the crime himself somehow
means he's innocent which is like really
wild
he's a cult leader yeah that also seems
to be a lot of that's what random
training is yeah and it's a lot of
excuses right the entertain situation
I mean racketeering is literally that
they invented that so they could
prosecute mob bosses because they never
actually committed the crimes right
that's what racketeering literally is
I feel bad for him though man if you
ever if you ever want to talk again bro
I'm here for you I'm not even joking
I'm here for you man
genuinely if you want to turn a new Leaf
it's not your fault it is not it's so
that's so on point it's not you're not
your fault
I'm genuinely here for you bro
because like
people you know I feel bad is people say
when you kill someone for the first time
it really sticks with you
and they're right
it's not your fault this wasn't your
first murder victim yeah I know I'm just
making a joke thank you
um and then what was your Take On The
Tourette's thing because my thing with
his Tourette's is like
he's made a whole career out of being a
motivational speaker because he overcame
Tourette's and obviously he didn't
notice I was like this is [__]
incredible because nobody else is going
to be able to accuse him of this [__]
you had a real Larry David moment with
that
but it is it is suspect
like I I see I don't have Tourette's so
I don't feel comfortable saying that I
mean I think it's certainly plausible uh
or or I don't think it's a stretch to
say that he had it and
like we were talking about before the
show the Nexium they did they have like
their therapy was like
these like seven pseudosciences and then
also cognitive behavioral therapy was a
bit of it too and that can like help
reduce ticks it helps you manage and
control them which it sounded like
that's what he was no he says no he said
he back he started backpedaling when he
realized I had Tourette's but on his
website and when he first came on he
says I have totally conquered my
Tourette's right that's not possible and
especially
if he was walking around saying the
n-word
that's like super super super severe
Tourette's so the fact that he went from
like fully blown like worst case
scenario Tourette's to like I am totally
I must sit here for an hour and not have
one visible tick is really [__] very
stressful insane too by the way why does
it lie at least for the second half but
I mean to me it's it's it's like saying
oh yeah I can I can cure bipolar disease
schizophrenia OCD just come talk to
Keith Bruner's he'll take care of it
like that's just not real
and then he backed up he said I'm four
out of 100 tourettes
right which that makes more sense I mean
you're saying that it was only because
you called him out I mean I definitely
backpedaled when I told him I had
Tourette's all right
I mean because he knows he he can't say
if he's selling some kind of course or
inspirational
you can't say I cured Tourette's right
he was tiptoeing around
fraud being fraudulent
um
yeah well as somebody with 35 Tourette
so let me tell you this
I know you'd say yours is 35 out of 100
yeah I don't use that four five percent
means everything
I feel bad for him though that was a lot
I bet Keith's on the phone with him
right now chewing him up way worse than
you are
I don't think Keith has access to a
phone oh you don't Keith is about to
release the photo of that guy like
having a pineapple up his ass or
something
that's it
so so now now that we have it confirmed
that he wasn't coming in here
you know trying to argue with you or
whatever and he really did think that
you would be sympathetic to his plight
was he just
Mass emailing like every podcast in
existence when we were just happened to
be the only one that took notice and it
could be he was copy pasting he said hi
dear HD oh yeah because dude okay okay
can you he addressed this email to Dear
H3 podcast highlights
oh I did catch I caught that that's
right he emailed me dear H3 podcast
highlights and I was about to erase it
because I was like this is a bot or some
[__] Indian farmer who's trying to
why the hell but then I was like oh [__]
I was like oh [__] my name is Mark
Elliott I'm award-winning speaker live
with Tourette for 20 years and I beat it
completely so already I'm perking up
like oh what the [__] and then I was
part of the now Infamous Nexium I'm like
what
yeah
and then he goes I recently saw your
coverage of poking holes in Andrew Tate
narrative yeah that's really the part
because up until that point it could be
like oh you were in the next game call
and you want to like talk about your
experience and stuff well then like it's
the Andrew Taylor when he said he'd be
off the rails a little bit no it was
when he said he beat Tourette's that's
when he went off the rails for me I was
like yo this guy's quiet tractor said he
was on Theo Vaughn's podcast once no
[__] shot we're watching that right
now talking about what he talks about uh
his Tourette's at one point uh the part
I'm watching so this is what I'm saying
this guy's built a whole career he's on
tour telling people they can cure their
Treads if they stop being [__] about
it
right which again would have made sense
if he knew that you had Tourette's and
was specifically reaching out to you
you're a famous influencer that has it
but it wasn't even that either it's the
H3 podcast highlights let me send you an
image of this because I think it's worth
seeing yeah that thumbnail is good Kim
obviously I didn't want to title it
because I didn't want to give the game
away and that's why I disabled chat too
and made a very cryptic title because
I really wanted this to land and you
have the the name of Theo's episode is
the man who overcame Tourette's see that
now to me
to me that's insanely [__]
offensive
you don't overcome Tourette's and the
implications that everyone else is weak
that everyone else is just being a giant
[__] who hasn't been enlightened yet
you don't it's not something you
overcome it's something you live with
and you learn to live with it's it's
crazy you can't it's just [__] up to
put that into the world
like oh yeah did you get your Tourette's
cured yet like people that watch that
it's crazy
um by the way let me send you this I
just want to show you um
so you can pull it up because this email
is pretty ironic pretty iconic and he he
was emailing you quite a lot right then
so he had a lot of opportunities to look
into the show
this all started like over two weeks ago
and so again
um if
you know
I ever found myself in a position where
I was being invited on a podcast I don't
know why that would ever happen uh but
if I did I would probably yeah I would
probably at least Google once well but
he emailed you like 30 times that's what
I'm saying is like there was plenty of
time and there was uh you know back and
forth and stuff as we uh tried to land
on a date to do this and um
yeah I don't know I don't know can you
pull it next time do a little bit of
research just a little
um but that's what I said I can
understand how you be how you fell into
this cold I mean you have zero critical
thinking abilities at the point and we
did there was quite a bit of back and
forth but it was very formal and brief
just about the logistics I know you know
I didn't go out of my way to try and
mislead him that we were gonna somehow
be we didn't say anything I I it's very
just like hi nice to meet you
um what dates would work for you just I
did the same I didn't want to be guilty
of misleading him or or or
and trapping him he emailed me I
responded was simply I afford it to Dan
I don't think I said I said hi Mark
would you be interested in calling into
our show that's all I said he said hi H3
thanks for getting back to me I'd love
to when were you thinking then I tagged
Dan I said oh my producer Dan email you
so like there was no
you know the rest of it was just like
technical stuff we handled that like
very professionally
can you show that email I want to show
how you addressed it to
uh here I'll just screenshot I guess
yeah it doesn't show any
there you go yeah here this is the email
I got he addressed me as dear H3 podcast
highlights
so very odd
you can't he's just
I don't know man like do you see how in
in a way if you're really impressed by
Keith you should be really impressed
what I just did
so and I well you haven't cured any uh
neurological disorders or anything so
well a stupid neurological disorder I
think he just got a pretty strong dose
and how not to be stupid
me from poverty do you find any good
excerpts from the Theo Von because I'm
sure he's out there being like yeah I
cured this [__] everyone else is a giant
lame-o also just real quick I want to
give a little bit of a shout out
to uh somebody on Reddit known as
Incorruptible BK who runs the Nexium
case uh subreddit
um you were a massive help in
researching this this weekend uh you've
really stayed on top of this whole case
and tracked it um I found a lot of
fantastic information on there and um I
see are they buzzing I see uh 55 minutes
ago that Incorruptible BK posted a link
to our episode on that subreddit said
maybe it's too late to catch it live but
Ethan Klein brought Mark Elliott on his
podcast and is just absolutely toying
with him so shout out to incorruptable
BK for your assistance
uh thank you Nick Clark for the 20. he
says I'm wheezing right now Bella
Simmons who's a legend said that was
amazing billiam what liquor
uh five gifted thank you God bless Nick
Clark 50. that was a rotiss that man was
a rotisserie chicken
are you watching the Cleveland thing
yeah nothing nothing too interesting yet
yeah if um if if you guys don't mind
because I didn't eat breakfast today can
you bring out uh we got Subway
I'm just going to eat to this side I
don't want to just make a disrupt the
experience or anything but
God damn that wouldn't like wake because
I was let's be honest we were talking
last night we were kind of nervous
so I don't know how this is gonna go
I'm sorry I mean yeah I still didn't
even
still didn't even know what his attitude
was because like again you can read that
same email as him being kind of
sarcastic towards you
I didn't like that I thought he it's
it's exactly what I thought it would be
in terms of it was no you absolutely it
was yeah the top commentatio Vons is
very inspiring to have a man who beat
Tourette's and a man who beat down
syndrome in the same room talking
I think Theo probably jokes that he has
Downs or something
so this guy's been on tour for four
years this is he had theoba he was on
video one show
you know
well that would have been before was
four years ago before everything came
crashing down on Nexium yeah it must
have been because when I watched the
first
documentary about Nexium
Keith was still out he was still at
large and then at one point he was on
the run in Mexico I don't know the whole
timeline
I feel bad for him though honestly at
the end of the day he was very even in
the face of like being called out he was
very um
mild-mannered
I don't know
that's what I was saying it's just it's
sad that he like this dude could
probably you know make something of
himself
in something that isn't defending a
convicted
child predator
well anyway Branch out if you Branch out
a little bit
if you're out there
watching Mark
I'm here for you buddy
I'll adopt you like Aiden Ross
that's sweet I already have two kids but
[__] what do you think you have a
brother I won't say their name to call
them out but what do you think of uh
this uh comment in the chat that we were
bullying him and it was really hard to
watch we were bullying him there's no
question about it that's why I feel bad
but at a certain point this man
he's so special because I can bully him
like he's worthy of being bullied
I mean for how dumb it was to approach
me he's literally part of a sex call
he's defending a pedophile rapist yeah I
mean I mean I think the point where
uh the sympathy kind of disappeared for
me is when
he wouldn't outright say it
but heavily implying that the child r
word victim was uh just making it up and
lying I would say that's worse than
bullying yeah that's pretty that's
pretty scary this girl who was brave
enough to come out
[Music]
in the age of 12. this man he he all but
said she's lying yeah
he didn't want to fully say that but you
know read between them there's 15 other
victims in uh they're all making it up
and he goes well they're not under oath
it's basically like a random tweet I was
like yeah a good thing yeah they don't
even know each other there's like they
weren't even like
known associates is that the girl he
said was just kinky too yeah wow that
was crazy yeah it was pinky they were
just kinky
that was embarrassing yikes so yeah
I think
we were definitely bullying him don't
get me wrong I mean I don't know if it
was bowling to be honest I'm being
facetious but we definitely grilled him
hard
and he walked into a giant trap and we
were talking about something very
serious
and I wanted to yeah what am I just fine
shut up
if you're uncomfortable enough for you
go join next to him I agree
they're they're all about the knife over
there
how's a sandwich it's actually really
good just give me a sec
just give me one sec give you a sec to
eat
yeah just kind of doing a show here
lunch time no no just give me a sec
okay
can I get a straw
oh there it is
okay
cool
[Music]
foreign
yeah hold on Mark I just gotta eat real
quick
[Music]
all right
together
[Music]
thank you
foreign
I don't know
why not stop olives
thank you
[Music]
just a little bit
perfect
[Music]
um
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
enough
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the wrong way today
[Music]
Virginia driver
s
[Music]
foreign
I love it
perfect
[Music]
come on
um
[Music]
thank you
obviously
[Applause]
thank you
yeah
[Music]
foreign
um
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
um
obviously
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
okay
because
it's so important
[Music]
and that's why
that interview was really I felt really
bad for him
but
thank you
enough
I'm done with my lunch now you good yeah
it was powerful okay
thank you
excuse me I know some people don't like
when I munch
so I thought I would take the time
move the mic away from my mouth and just
eat my lunch like a civilized person
and you guys didn't have to hear me
chewing yeah I think the fan base
actually really appreciates that
um I'll be totally honest
38 000 people still watching that's more
than I thought
you know uh that's how you know this is
a cult [__] nixium y'all just watch me
eat Subway for 20 minutes in dead
silence no podcast has the balls bro to
bring you 20 minutes of dead air
that's confidence you know what I mean
they say the Geniuses have to know the
rules before they break them
that's what
20 minutes silently eating Subway
is oh by the way so I wanted this to be
really authentic I sent Zach out
and they wanted to get ambient sounds
like but I said no
yeah to be clear this was this is
completely Ethan's brainchild he was
very
excited and passionate about the segment
where are you Dan I was kind of nodding
off a little bit so I leaned the
Scorpion chair back okay I can't see it
can you not see me well show the show
the pic of uh Zach
yeah there he is there's your beautiful
eyes I'll leave the neighbor from Home
Improvement
Wilson
show Zach
or do I have it it's in the dock oh it's
in the dark
I sent Zach all out our sound boy
on a very special mission
um I don't know where it is in this
document at the top right here I have a
highlight
there it is
check it out I wanted this to be genuine
as possible
there's Zach at Subway
recording
you know
I noticed something while we were
listening to it I could hear Zach
chewing yeah I I wanted it so like I
crinkled the paper and Chantal went with
me so she was my uh co-engineer on this
um and
um just we lit the mic roll for like 20
minutes and
the staff at Subway were really cool I
said at work I go to Pierce College and
uh we're doing a semester project is it
cool if we get some ambient noises
and then we're really cool
well so we identified a problem going in
I think it was Zach said well Subway
always plays music I says you gotta go
in there and just tell him to turn off
the music ask him to turn off the music
for 30 minutes and they did and they did
yeah so it was really cool of them so
shout out to uh that Subways yeah and
good job Zach thank you I knew that the
subway ambient sounds were important and
they were good
they were they were I was there you know
in subway now did you transported you
did you hear
little fart that made its way into that
somewhere in that Loop
I I think it went by twice I think it
was just me I thought maybe you were
farting I mean it could have been
I mean the chat's talking about it too
they're all talking about fart gate
did you fart Jack did you fart Jack I
didn't fart I mean you were recording
I'm a sensitive mic I don't know dude
that's I'll tell you what that sandwich
hit hard bro
um
you know sometimes it hits the spot Dan
can you show uh I walk into the back of
a screen
this is very rude I mean it's quite rude
Daniel
I've told you this chair is kind of
uncomfortable and I'm I'm kind of I'm
kind of comfortable right now okay
I won't push you all right fine hold on
that was the perfect
way to decompress after a stressful call
too you know I was thinking like this
interview is probably gonna get some new
eyeballs because it was pretty wild so
it's like someone's like oh let me check
out this H3 I heard this interview is
good so they watched the interview and
they're like oh let me watch the rest of
the episode then it's just me sitting
there silently eating Subway for 20
minutes well Jared Fogle and Keith
reniere have a lot in common you know
they both wear glasses and other reasons
right right I think Keith lost weight I
think he was a little bit bigger back in
the day potentially defeated from Subway
he defeated being fat mind over body and
both are innocent they've been it's a
good a lot yeah pretty Jared dude
foot long
Jared is one of the greatest stories of
all times like the downfall of Jared
he's like this app this not only is he
like a predator a child p word Predator
they get him on a call like salivating
the call was so gross Bro Jared has gone
full Joker it was a I think Discovery
plus is about to drop a donkey series on
him too oh really yeah my boy
why'd you have to go [__] kid or I don't
know if he did he just had it
does not ruin a good time let's not ruin
a good time
by talking about that stuff yeah no
we're having fun here yeah so what else
we got here today thanks for joining us
today um
Subway meta Mark
um
Nexium uh Courier yeah and I guess we
have landlord tick tock
because landlord Tick Tock do they also
have the guy who talks [__] to the
delivery robots which really cracked me
up
[Music]
I love him
let's watch that then
so there's this account film
the robots la
goes around LA area trying to get into
altercations with food delivery robots
which maybe we should just explain that
that is a thing because I know if it's
that common outside of major cities like
La I did not know this was a thing I've
seen them around so what are they
delivering it's like ubereats and [__]
or like uh yeah doordash and all the
Office Buildings
yeah they're generally in like downtown
areas uh I recognize it seemed like
these videos were all in like
the core City area of La yeah they go up
and down Melrose all the time yeah
that's sort of me Lena first saw them
went to Hollywood I [__] hate them
this is
scary this is how worthless you are as
workers
they invented a [__] robot to avoid
paying you minimum wage barely minimum
and it's awesome because they probably
the robot probably cost a [__] ton and
it's so much worse it's so slow oh that
they're so bad like dude you're not even
you're not even paying the minimum wage
with that have they got to pay for those
cars and that's still too much for you I
can't do that they still got to
Outsource that
let's watch here's uh two robots
blocking each other I like this guy
bring it to the robots [__] them [__]
idiots turn on your [__] lights
turn on your [__] lights
yeah
it's all your life they need to be on no
he's absolutely right no no one turn
your [__] lights this is reckless
now I want to see you navigate that
[__] up there because that's really
that many robots
they're just colliding
let's see you figure this one out taking
up the whole damn sidewalk just go
around it why don't you tell your boy
to move the [__] out of the way you guys
are a hazard
push them push them it's speeding dude
you don't even know what to do you're
gonna have to go around
because his dumb ass is sitting there
you don't have any [__] lights
you did some ass don't there's any
lights the page is just in the way
this is great Tech the man has a point
fire the workers
oh okay I'm a good maneuver
oh now Paige is moving
they got some zombies how is this
[__] worth using did you hear what
you said there no
now we got a couple zombies following
the robot
oh this is super weird this I didn't
know these robots were a thing
Darren wanted to run over his foot okay
lawsuit incoming you [__] touched me
you touched me you touched me you talked
but it's a private person's arrest don't
you touch it don't let you have someone
watching over like the webcam on the
robot just being like what in the [__]
no they probably know this guy by now
I'm not this guy again yeah yeah
that's a yeah backup said that's right
Zed yes yeah
how soon until people start smashing
these this is like real life loot boxes
man if yeah oh true
box people used to like smash bird
scooters all the time
this is the new meta what is the new
meta okay you could just follow them so
those are the ones that I've seen I hate
these things is that real yeah yeah I
have never seen that oh I've seen these
uh in a few places they they have them
as like patrolling outside uh buildings
it's really just a harass unhoused
people yeah basically what does it do it
makes annoying noise does that a fire
flamethrower on it there's it's not arms
made by NASA I think I honestly I think
all it really is is a [__] security
camera that can roll around
it's effectively all Annoying noises to
clear people out and if it's like
something unruly they'll call the real
police right
okay that's pretty cool how much did
that cost uh two and a half million
dollars okay
how much do you pay your security guards
uh minimum wage you know where I saw
them was speaking of wasting money on
this [__] they always have them
patrolling outside of [__] Kaiser
Hospital Kaiser hmm the one in the east
L.A or whatever the one in Hollywood
yeah
these [__] got robots outside
and I gotta wait that's what I'm saying
you don't have anything better you can
spend that money on yeah
let's get another doctor here so I can
[__] see a doctor without waiting
you got robot money
[__] you [__] oh yeah that's right
[Music]
the delivery driver
oh
he ain't [__] you acting like you're
[__] talk
with your stupid ass sounds
[__] Egghead
yeah look at me
you ain't scaring nobody
those dumb ass sounds
I think this guy might start a
revolution
he's getting ready we gotta fight back
I am I'm feeling hostile robots I don't
like what they represent me neither
I like him his name is films the robots
La so
we love that for him
here's a robot driving by that he's he
uh Road rages look at you yeah your
mother's a washing machine
that's probably so your mother's a
[__] washing machine
[Laughter]
that's awesome
holy [__] dude this is really happening
out there I had no idea yeah right here
in Los Angeles I think a lot of people
who aren't here are going to be shocked
by it get down uh you know I figured
that
um I have seen in the chat people uh
throwing out you know not small towns by
any means cities but you know places
other than like La New York San
Francisco which is where I assumed it
would have been I saw somebody say they
have them in Phoenix
um which you know is like a medium-sized
City and I'll be back I think I saw a
couple places in Texas too people
shouting out so yeah they're they're
spreading this is happening
[Music]
this is happening right under our nose
they're being deployed Nationwide let me
just said we have them in Charlotte
North Carolina so they're even in North
Carolina don't you guys see what's
happening
I'll be back they get them in there
delivering food as a guys yeah we all
goddamn know that these robots are
horrible at delivering food it's so
stupid
you would way rather pay someone with
minimum wage there's something else
going on
[Music]
also clearly the robot isn't gonna um
deliver it to your door
like you can't get upstairs it can't do
anything like that so like it's
genuinely just like it seems like it's a
worse experience in every way
that's like a downgrade wait what the
cam you took this video Yeah in
Massachusetts
where the [__] does this thing do they
have these [__] googly eyes here
how about just lower the price of eggs
yeah
what does it do that [__] thing is
designed to
um detect spills in the grocery store
like a human can do that but it really
just gets in the [__] way I hate the
tech spills yeah like a dude with a mop
isn't better right
what [__] you Marty the robot if you're
watching idiot dumbass [__] step to the
side Roblox
step to the side you better figure it
out
you can navigate that can't you Jordan
Jordan if you can't navigate that you
shouldn't be on the road that's true
yeah the Agility Test come on Jordan you
got to do it somebody's food is getting
cold hi hello
go ahead you ain't gonna buy me off with
a little hello you're afraid you're
afraid if you touch my foot I'm gonna
file a private person's arrest on your
ass Jordan
get on with the delivery get out of here
get out of here
you can't even get over a little crack
look at his ass bounced back and then
like like right this has nothing to do
with me
it's tick tock
that's pretty funny I like that back so
do you guys like the one where a twitch
streamer pretends to steal her own phone
some dog getting run over I don't love
that
um just so you know we are at three
hours so uh you were not obligated to uh
although 20 minutes of that I guess was
just you eating a Subway sandwich yeah
honestly I I wasn't sure how we would go
on after that interview it was nice as a
palette cleanser uh I know you probably
don't agree I feel like it went on maybe
just a little too that's what makes it
funny I feel like we went through the
whole it's going on too long and now
it's funny and I feel like we arrived at
like the secondary okay now it's really
enough no but that you push through that
you don't but I feel like we already got
through the first one like it's so funny
and then it's like okay this is getting
old okay it's gone so long it's funny
again and then we arrived at no for real
though you're wrong okay
I had to do this for three hours this
one man and then people really called me
avant-garde oh God don't put it back Ian
what are you doing
hmm
no I'm not gonna do that again I don't
like those chips
what kind of chips
you're gonna hate me but they're just
not good oh miss Vicky's jalapeno those
are the [__] it's just not hitting for
me
take it down be good be with God
Dan just snatched my chips
you guys okay so let's do One More Story
do you guys want landlord Tick Tock
bugle fat removal
Buckle fat removal
or twitch streamer steals her own phone
let's do a poll again let the people oh
the twitch streamer steals their own
phone
let's let the people it's Snappy it's
funny you just want to eat your chips
bro I need you to work right now
okay
so what's so often
buccal fat removal
put streamer steals her own phone how
the [__] do you spell that again
b-u-c-c-a-l
uh-huh
you landlord Tick Tock landlord
and phone so there's three options
dreamer steals own phone
everybody look at your phone right now
let's ask the community
different perspective different
perspectives that's what that's what
Mark needs he needs to talk to garyvee
then at least he'll just take his money
not his
you know what marketing he needs a v
friend
now put that phone down
perspectives
oh streamer steals their own phones if
it used to be a blower that's an
interesting okay Dan you are right
actually
you were right on the money it's a very
cringe clip as you usually are
sometimes is being right so frequently a
burden or a blessing
it's a burden
because your help does such a high
standard
impossible standard really I'm just
gonna fart
maybe you should intentionally get
things wrong so that you could be more
of a middle that's what I do anytime you
see me make a mistake or say something
incorrectly factually untrue I'm really
trying to lower the bar a little bit not
to intimidate you Dan is the man
very smart all right well let's do it
then our final story of the day is a
tick or a twitch streamer
uh she's polish
no it's this from Singapore yeah no I
was looking at the uh the dog run over
one no what the [__] was this dog one
she hit a dog online yeah yeah she was
driving she's like why there's so many
dogs on the road a few seconds later
checks her phone did she just run it
down
yeah oh she's on her phone yeah she got
the car it's pretty [__] up I'm not
gonna show the video but I'm gonna watch
it here play it
no don't play the song oh this sounds
bad it's weird at the end oh don't play
the sound Jesus Christ and then she got
she got banned I haven't watched it yeah
keemstar's still allowed on Twitch and
he ran over a dog on Christmas Day
didn't stream it though right
that is really sad that is really sad
man
she was driving a car talking to chat
why what are you doing is that legal in
uh Poland
no probably not a split moment something
could be heard hitting the car
that's really sad
did the dog die
I could not find that out oh you know
what I think I read that the dog was
fine she just ran over the other exactly
the dog is okay well that's what she
even saying that's what she is saying to
be fair which is oh yeah I saw it
obviously have we seen the dog
do we know dude I hope she's not lying
that what that would dig your grave even
deeper Jesus
I feel like if you ran over a dog the
first thing you would show to your
stream is proof of life no no I would
have kept driving well actually Mark
Elliott made a statement he's in favor
he's saying the girls innocent
that's a joke
thank you all right let's get to the
main story here
uh not about dead dogs Okay so this one
is Kira Kitty
21 year old switch streamer from
Singapore
who does study chat and bikini streams I
saw a lot of people being like Oh I hate
her she's the worst so does she have
some kind of reputation or am I is it
just whatever
like like
typical woman streamers
she's like a iron streamer what do you
mean by that Ethan no because like
there's oh there's an army of incels
that [__] on all typical especially ones
that wear like bikinis
so is it just that or is she done actual
other things
um
I don't know it's she's an only thing
for me for a long time so I'm sure if
none of us are familiar we probably
shouldn't she also apparently has a
website where she sells bathwater farts
and stockings I'm on her I'm on her link
tree sounds she sounds bass then
yeah she used to be involved with like
ice Poseidon back in the day so I
remember oh she's probably a terrible
person then no no no no but she hasn't
been streaming with any anyone on like
the Isis Island community so yesterday
she was having a study session in the
library
when her phone streaming camera was
suddenly taken away
here's the clip
I can see why she uh
people just sit in the library and
stream that like what the this shit's
out of control what are we doing here
she's oh well okay I just did Subway for
20 minutes who am I okay I was about
wasn't sure if you were self-aware when
you were saying that or not but I'm glad
you know but the way I did it was
interesting the way that they did it was
you're a [__] hypocrite
so uh here it is she let's just watch
by the way is Singapore like a gorgeous
country because this is the nicest
Library I've ever seen Singapore is very
wealthy well [__] this is like the
future of library before people get mad
at me
I'm sure the wealth inequality there is
also insane yeah but yeah um it's one of
it's sort of the uh
banking center of uh Asia so okay
there's a lot of like finance and stuff
that happens there and
foreign
just it's a very nice Library wherever
it is is a great Library beautiful
really
stunning
[Music]
wait when did the snatch happen
because
right at the right here
this is the snatch this is but why is it
already streaming then she so she was
streaming from her phone so the oh she
went did she go to the bathroom or
something yeah oh okay so she got up
into the bathroom kept streaming
riveting stuff here
because that was her study space it was
right there there was a clip that went
kind of viral of another IRL streamer
who got her phone stolen so I'm guessing
she got inspiration from that
[Music]
um
okay here it is
so someone is
snagging her phone
[Music]
anyone in that library is not stealing
anything
look at that who what library has
ambient lighting dude
oh so you dropped the phone it showed
her face and then she immediately ended
the stream and embarrassment come on
now my so when the phone was dropped by
the quote Thief it was revealed that it
was Kira Kitty who pretended to steal
her own phone then abruptly ended it
he's unclear whether she'll face any
consequence what consequence I mean just
people in comments are saying that they
hope people ban her and this is stupid
okay they're gonna so easily played that
off that she was just [__] around
yeah totally could have just she did let
out a few Giggles before ending it but
people were like the fact that she ended
it and didn't talk about it is very
embarrassing
I have no problem with him she's just
trying to make interesting content who
gives a [__] she's sitting in a library
of course it's I don't think she should
get in trouble oh my God she sits in a
library in a bikini
that's kind of interesting how we're
talking I thought there was no shoes no
shirt no service repelling content this
is good so here okay now I get why
people are watching
this is good
you can sit in a bikini
in a library this this why not I mean
with that lighting she's basically in
like a tanning bed
getting some getting some rays
got nice libraries here in L.A too yeah
right bro excuse me when's the last time
you've been to the Central Library does
it have well-lit shelves bikinis I don't
know about the bikini bro if you go to a
public library in La all you're going to
see is like a homeless dude jerking off
you are so
yo
yo never mind how dare you if you go to
a public school in the library you're
100 guaranteed to see an old weird
vagrant off it's very safe Los Angeles
Public Library System you know what Dan
you know Dan I I I'm sorry again I
didn't mean to cut you off you go for it
go for it Zack
um I support the library system but
Ethan is 100 right oh God I I've
actually gone to the libraries here a
lot and they're very nice me too that's
what I'm saying we could have good
libraries here
lots of shitty things about LA and you'd
be right the libraries are nice
beautiful mural in there there's no
people jacking off in there maybe
there's people in bikinis
it's a gorgeous building dude I've seen
so many people take a [__] in the
planter which Library I mean which one
the one in the valley so many people
take a [__] in the plants how many times
have you seen that happen you literally
[__] you are that guy
it was a lawn it wasn't a library
Dan does have a good point Zach
it was a lawn
I'm not just animal
wow this is gorgeous is there where's a
good place to jerk off in this joint
the public computers man
you mean [__] creepers are tossing
off there yeah it's it's a lot I'm
scared to even look at their monitors or
at them when I see people like that oh
sticky dude and just to plug the LA
Public Library a little bit more they
have uh
public 3D printers for Central Library
now that you can come in and use for
free
hang you down like why yeah
the library is a good resource everyone
should sign up sign up get a library
free previous card actually it's a
beautiful card it's don't show the back
don't don't talk to your number
it's look at that you hear that people
are gonna check out no no no no I'm
gonna check out a thousand books people
are gonna check out so many books with
your car I'm gonna have so many
overdraft fees look at this guy yeah
he's got a he's got a rare one the one
time I got sent to collections
I didn't have credit I didn't even know
anything about it when I was in college
but I
checked out a book from the school
library
for a project
and I forgot to return it
they sent that [__] to collections for
like five hundred dollars wait the
school yes thank you to collection yes
and then I found out like years later
when I was like trying to do something
with credit I never knew and they're
like there's a huge red flag on your
credit report no yeah a [__] book
from the library or a book huh dude
that's the Seinfeld episode The library
card yeah
[__]
that is [__]
um this is so funny it's unclear if
she'll face consequences but some
commenters are calling for it what are
you talking about dummies they come on
under the Reddit livestream fails
uploaded said honestly at this point I
wish our mods would go back to Banning
streamers I don't know I don't care
so seriously it's just it's embarrassing
I I personally I don't even think it's a
problem like people are making content
on this platform all the time doing all
kinds of outrageous [__] who cares the
outrage around like bikini streamers and
like whenever they do anything wrong
people just come down super hard on them
because they don't want them on the
platform so yeah it is
uh Aiden Ross by the way he goes I think
dude this just happened think about this
he put out a statement I think hot tub
booby streamers whatever need to be
banned from twitch meanwhile I'll be on
Kik streaming porn porn to a bunch of
teenagers like bro
you're so dumb
so dumb dude so dumb quite dumb
okay that's the story well I ca she's
acquitted I forg I uh face consequences
we need to
the twitch governing body needs to make
a statement on this egregious Act
so many this is the worst thing about
twitch is all these [__]
sweaty in-cell basement dwelling [__]
weird gamers
just say Gamers Gamers yeah gamers
we need to hold her accountable
[Music]
all right well [__] that was a whole
journey I mean the the interview was
really everything that was the center
thing like the episode for sure so so by
the way so we put in the new thumbnail
so now we need a good title
uh obviously this one so let's say
the virtues of the Los Angeles Public
Library no Cameron
Zach will come take a [__] in its
planner no Los Angeles library perfect
how about this debating Nexium cult
member is that too harsh here's the
thing you were concerned about the title
triggering red flags is Nexium cults
you got to do confronting Nexium cult
member well that is good that is that's
true that's why I Love It Best in the
game so confronting Nexium
that's the game cult member
that's powerful that's pretty good
on uh Mark should we put his full name
or is that dirty because it's going to
show up every time first result for his
name now if we put his name in it
has any
power in terms of search and you know
what I mean
yeah
I feel so powerful what I was gonna say
is confronting Nexium cult member Mark
Elliott
I just don't know
you're right it it all it really does is
just kind of make it forever associated
with him on the internet and nobody
knows who he is anyways so I don't so
how about confronting Nexium cold
apologist on Keith reneres or something
or just I don't know if Keith's name is
important
maybe confronting
on and then the title of or the name of
the Netflix documentary
because that has a lot of clicks that's
a juicer title right there SEO okay okay
wow so how about a Nexium apologist from
the vowel or no confrontal member he's
part he's in D remember yeah confronting
Nexium cult member
[Music]
on Keith by the way people are saying
curing your Tourette's I thought about
that but I think YouTube might actually
not like that right that actually people
are suggesting that because that was our
original title yeah
if we went with that I feel like he
would have suspected Something Fishy too
yeah yeah yeah definitely I don't
I don't know well I don't even think he
was aware of anything I'm surprised that
guy dude can breathe
[Music]
he's got to like control everybody
um
confronting Nexium cult member
and eating a Subway sandwich for 20
minutes
confronting Nexium cult member from that
was featured on the belt from the vowel
who was featured on the Belt that's
gonna work I think just from the bow or
just featured
featured oh [__] no yeah so this is how
unaware he was man
look at this he tweeted this [__] out
going live shortly on HG podcast to
discuss FBI tampering in U.S
versus Syrian beating Tourette's again
he says in his tweet he beat Tourette's
what does that mean you don't beat
threats it's not cancer you can beat
cancer you don't have cancer anymore
Tourette's is not like that
foreign
did he erase the tweet yet or is it
still up
he probably erased it
maybe we shook him hard enough he's
gonna quit he's gonna you know wake up
and
smell it he's gonna wake up maybe he
just has the attitude that you know what
there's 40 000 people watching this live
right now at least one of them is gonna
sign up for nexium at the end of this I
think he's gonna make one conversion
I think he's gonna wake up
and smell the vinyl chloride right
confronting Nexium cult member with
Keith in the thumbnail
we have to use the thumbnail we have
both of them
confronting Nexium cult member featured
on in Netflix stock
or why don't we say
it wasn't Netflix what was the name of
the it was HBO yeah oh okay featured in
the vowel
you guys like that one
pretty Nexium cult member featured in
The Vow
that's nice I think that's it that's
good that's good that's good locking it
in hitting save there we are
also with the LA Public Library Card you
get access to Libby app which is free
audiobooks really yep that's that's not
audible you don't have to deal with
anybody jacking off you can just listen
in a book
jacking off in a book you can just
listen to it all on your app
that's pretty cool
I stand corrected the library is not
just a place to jerk off in public
so much more
no way look at this Dono that we just
got from Kendall music
I'm playing a festival with David Guida
he's a super cool dude in June and as
your boss girl EDM dj fupa Trooper Stan
I they said Vogue I'm pretty sure they
meant vow vow to show him the sound bite
and get a shout out to the H3 Family
Video
that would be
email it to me whatever do whatever you
got to do that is so awesome wait who is
this person Kendall is she uh Carter
apparently uh
she is 40 000 on Instagram
Kendall music
Kendall music Kendall oh I get it we
love Kendall
she's my favorite musician we're cool
ever we love David weed make it happen
please if you can rock so hard
uh what were we talking about okay so
yeah confronting you guys like that
confronting Nexium cult member featured
in The Vow
I do like all facts I like it
I guess that's it then
oh did you update the thumbnail yet Dan
sure did although it doesn't show me the
old one stock yeah hold on
Let me refresh
Spock has rules
I can literally do anything
yeah
it's showing the new one I think it just
needs a minute to refresh on YouTube
said oh anything else we should what's
today's Monday so today is Monday you
gotta
on Friday yet
I assume so on Friday she said let's
wait until a day closer
it's closer when can I confirm it now oh
I can say it yeah Tana's on Friday yes
okay good yeah
that'll be fun a solo app with Tana
closer to the day okay
yeah I'm excited we had you know what I
mean she's that'll be fun also working
on getting shirtless Eddie to call in
that'll be a real treat
making a little progress uh
I've been texting him so uh dude what's
your secret how'd you get him I've been
in his lives
and I finally got him he's a true fan
smart because he follows me and likes my
tick tocks but he didn't respond to my
DMs he's been like commenting on the
podcast Tick Tock account too and like
DM dming there dude them
you said dming them isn't that you H3
podcast account I said
are we on band on no no
let me start over who's he dming the
podcast account
the podcast account yes that's us yeah
correct I know that he's bad it's banned
well before the bun oh
says you've been trying to get a hold of
him I I did mention it I think
oh imagine it Love's been deep
undercover with Eddie this whole time
anyways he we're gonna get him we're
gonna get him I have his number I just
like first message him like hey here's
my phone number text me I think he's in
La maybe we can even get alive oh yeah
I'll go share this with them he's a
working actor that'd be so fun I'll go
shirtless with him to Walmart or
wherever he wants you want him in studio
yeah well I think it'd be fun to do his
bit together at least to go shirtless
species that's my dream dude can I be
the person that says put your shirt on
I'm sure I love that
I'd love that for you
my my big break in Hollywood
um
I don't know okay anyway so that's it
guys I hope yeah this was a crazy
episode
no crazy holy smokes one of my faves
I gotta go watch that back that was wild
well
uh also program oh wait no it's next
week isn't it I was gonna say about
leftovers but
as there is leftovers this week but off
the following week yeah okay this is the
song will be Japan he's going to Japan
I'm jealous who said he could take time
off
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys see you on tomorrow for
members members we love our members I'll
be doing a solo app for you guys
tomorrow see you next Tuesday and then
Wednesday we'll be back as usual for off
the rails thank you so much love you so
much this is Ethan from Subway
signing out
[Music]